Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Pretlav und ich sage hallo hier zu Corona Weekly mit mir und mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Das ist die vierundsechzigste Ausgabe von Corona Wiekli. Wir haben heute den zwölften Mai äh nein,
noch nicht, Entschuldigung, wir haben den zwölften März zwanzig einundzwanzig wir schauen zwar immer in die Zukunft aber wir reisen noch nicht dahin
Ja genau, wir haben wieder ein äh Ping,
volles Programm für euch ist doch so einiges passiert hinter den Kulissen und auch in aller Öffentlichkeit natürlich,
Wir werden wieder ein paar Zahlen zusammenfegen und so weiter. Vielleicht da ich jetzt auch nochmal auf die Downloadzahlen letzte Woche geschaut habe und festgestellt habe, dass es da nochmal ein erheblich gesteigertes Interesse gab.
Vielleicht eine kurze Hintergrundinformation nochmal hier zum Format als solchen
UKW ist ja eigentlich ein ja ein Podcast, der sich mit vielen Themen beschäftigen soll, aber wie es eben nun mal so kam, haben wir einen totalen Schwerpunkt hier,
auf die Gronakrise und Pavel und ich machen das jetzt hier seit ja, seit einem Jahr jetzt genau, ne? Das ist jetzt
soweit, also wir hatten tatsächlich die allererste Sendung, genau vor einem Jahr aufgenommen, gerade als klar war, Lokdown jetzt äh geht's irgendwie los, ne
schau grad nochmal genau nach dem Datum, ja dreizehnter dritter, also wirklich genau vor einem Jahr
Und seitdem haben wir ähm uns, wenn man jetzt mal von so einer kleinen Sommerpause absieht, hier wöchentlich eilig um dieses Thema gekümmert,
uns die Zahlen angeschaut, aber dann eben im zunehmenden Maße auch all das versucht umzusetzen und zu artikulieren,
so es uns selber auch klar geworden ist, so wie wir uns selber damit beschäftigt haben
Wir sind also jetzt keine Hobbyvirologen und oder vielleicht sind wir Hobbyvirologen, aber wir sind halt auch gleichzeitig Hobby, Statistiker, Hobby, Mathematiker, Hobby, was weiß ich, irgendwie.
Hobbywissenschaftskommunikatoren.
Ja, das das trifft's vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen besser, ne? Also wir äh versuchen einfach nur zu vermitteln, was wir selber verstanden haben aus dem, was, was eben so rumliegt und das liegt ja eine ganze Menge rum. Studien über alles mögliche, Ereignisse, über alles Mögliche.
Ja.
Und das macht auch immer noch Spaß. Pavel hat dann halt irgendwann angefangen eine große Zahlentabelle zusammenzutragen, die Risikotabelle. Da gehen wir jetzt gleich auch nochmal im Detail drauf ein, weil sich da ja eine ganze Menge getan hat
und ja, wir planen ähm das jetzt das Format so fortzuführen,
solange es Bedarf gibt, sprich solange diese Krise noch zu viel Unwegbarkeiten für uns alle bietet, aber auch sagen wir mal,
seiner ganzen Entwicklung her interessant bleibt, bleiben wir hier am Ball und ja und wenn ihr,
UKW noch nicht kanntet oder vielleicht auch die Meterebene noch nicht kanntet, dazu vielleicht auch nochmal ein Wort, also Meterebene,
das ist so mein Podcast Projekt von mir, Tim Prittler, ich mache das mittlerweile seit fünfzehn Jahren.
Und habe eine ganze Menge Podcasts gestartet und ich mache eigentlich auch eine ganze Menge Podcast noch parallel,
Da könnt ihr mal auf Meterebene ME schauen, da ist so einiges zu finden. Äh für jeden Geschmack was dabei. Ich habe auch schon immer sehr viel mit Wissenschaft gemacht, Raumzeit ist ein Podcast über
Raumfahrt, Forschergeist ist ein Podcast, der sich mit sehr vielen unterschiedlichen Disziplinen,
der Wissenschaft beschäftigt und gerade auch in den letzten Folgen und Spoiler Alard auch in der nächsten Folge voraussichtlich auch nochmal spezifisch mit Fragestellungen rund um die Corona-Krise auch beschäftigt.
So wie das auch äh dann auch bei Lokbuch Netzpolitiken, Podcasts mit Linus, Neumann zusammen mache, auch wöchentlich,
auch öfter niederschlägt, da haben wir uns zum Beispiel.
Diese Woche gerade über solche Themen wie den digitalen Impfpass und so weiter ordentlich die Bäuche gehalten,
Das sind dann alles so Sachen, die wir jetzt hier nicht machen. Hier ist unser Fokus einfach ganz klar auf den Zahlen und Parametern, die unser aller Leben in dieser Krise im Wesentlichen so begleiten und mitsteuern
Ihr könnt äh diesen Podcast auch unterstützen, mit der Ebene Punkt ME, ne, nicht DE, ME Slash äh.
Spenden ist eure Möglichkeit hier dazu beizutragen dieses.
Format und viele andere Formate der Mieterebene weiterhin tragbar zu machen. So, genug der Vorrede,
steigen wir mal ein, Pavel, deine tolle Risikotabile, hat zwar immer noch keine eigene Domäden bekommen,
Ich baue jetzt hier mal ein bisschen Druck auf. Aber du hast ja letzte Woche angekündigt, dass da umfangreiche Umbaumaßnahmen äh erforderlich waren und wenn ich das richtig sehe, hast du die ganze Woche dich mit,
Projekt rumgeschlagen.
Ja, nicht die ganze Woche, aber äh so äh jetzt so die letzten beiden Tage und es,
sozusagen dann auch der
Punkt einer Arbeit, die mich immer wieder mal Monate beschäftigt äh hat oder seit Monaten äh ich äh immer mal wieder äh so ein paar Stunden mich rangesetzt hatte, aber jetzt,
habe ich halt in einem Push äh so das Ganze jetzt fertig gemacht. Das war dann doch noch einen ganz schöner Akt.
Bevor ich wieder alle Spalten der Tabelle füllen konnte, also es ging dann los irgendwann hatte ich's dann so hatte ich's dann so die ersten Spalten dann drin, aber,
das hat dann immer noch irgendwie anderthalb Tage gedauert, bis dann wirklich die Daten für alle Spalten berechnet waren und äh ja ähm.
Im Wesentlichen bis auf alles, was unter Fälle strickt, sieben Tage steht, äh da,
ist die äh sind die Zahlen noch so nicht korrekt, da ist noch ein Fehler drin, aber alle anderen Zahlen äh sind halt äh perfekt,
Also insofern äh dass sie halt mit
täglich auch veröffentlichten Zahlen genau übereinstimmen. Also die die Fallzahlen jetzt bei,
neu oder die Gesamtzahl der Fälle oder Gesamtzahl der Sterbefälle und alles was daraus abgeleitet ist, dass
ist halt ja äh soweit ich sehen kann absolut korrekt,
was halt ich dann noch nachdem ich dann in der Begeisterung, als es dann heute früh funktionierte
nach mehr oder weniger durchgearbeiteter Nacht
und ich die Tabelle dann online gestellt hatte, kam dann ganz schnell so die Meldung hier wegen äh ja aber sieben Tage äh Institanz ist ja nicht richtig so. Also die
sagen weicht ja jetzt von dem ab, was auf dem RKI-Dashboard zu sehen ist und.
Dann hatte ich eigentlich ja wie gesagt diese Fälle strikt sieben Tage um das zu berechnen, aber diese Berechnungen sind noch nicht ganz korrekt, da muss ich nochmal nochmal rüber.
Weil ich ja naiver Weise angenommen hatte, dass Fälle, die in weniger als sieben Tagen auch gemeldet werden, dann auch in die sieben Tage Institz eingehen, aber das tun sie halt in,
nur zu bestimmten Zeitpunkten, aber der eigentliche Punkt ist äh so, wo ich dann nochmal genau drauf gestoßen bin, weil ich habe dann halt nachgerechnet. Es ist halt so,
Du kannst halt ganz einfach natürlich gucken, wie viele Fälle wurden jetzt in den letzten sieben Tagen einfach
neu gemeldet oder du nimmst den absoluten Fallstand
von vor sieben Tagen und vergleiche sie mit heute, also ziehst es eine von dem anderen ab und kriegst halt eine Zahl von Fällen raus für,
Deutschland für die Bundesländer oder auch für jeden einzelnen Landkreis ist halt einfach so, weil die,
Zahlen fallen da halt alle ganz klar raus so. Und jetzt würde man ja naiver Weise denken so okay, hm wenn ich jetzt die sieben Tage Instit,
haben will, nehme ich doch einfach die äh in den letzten sieben Tagen gemeldeten Fälle und dann habe ich das.
Wir hatten vorher schon ja das Thema diskutiert oder immer wieder und viele andere auch, dass halt Fälle unter den Tisch fallen, weil,
ja das RKI eben die sieben Tagesinstitenz nicht auf Basis der in den letzten sieben Tagen,
veröffentlichten Fälle nimmt, sondern auf Basis des Meldedatums bei.
Äh Gesundheitsamt. Also sagen, wenn das äh Meldedatum,
Beim Gesundheitsamt länger als sieben Tage zurückliegt
aber der Fall erst gestern beim RKI eingetroffen und erst gestern gezählt wurde so dann zählt er halt für die Institenz nicht mit
Das muss man halt wissen,
führt halt zu verschiedenen Problemen natürlich noch erstens, wie gesagt, dass die veröffentlichten Zahlen und die sieben Tage Institenz nicht übereinstimmen in bestimmten Fällen, gerade auf Landkreisebene,
stellst du fest, die offizielle sieben Tage Instit,
runtergegangen, aber die Zahl der Fälle ist gestiegen, so von einer Woche auf die andere, so. Das.
Ist halt auch, würde ich sagen, erstmal nicht intuitiv. Äh.
Kann man so sagen, ja.
Ja. Ähm so und das zweite Problem ist, äh dass ja noch Fälle dazukommen,
für ein bestimmtes Meldedatum, das heißt, wenn die Institanz auf Basis des Meldedatums berechnest, ändert sie sich nachträglich.
Das heißt, die sieben Tage Instit von heute ist in einer Woche eine andere als heute.
Beim RKI zumindest.
Ja, aber das äh interessiert natürlich nicht für irgendwelche Entscheidungen oder so, das ist dann halt einfach gelaufen,
So
und äh ja, wie gesagt, ich kann's ganz verstehen, wo das Ganze herkommt, wo man da herkommt, natürlich möchte man lieber mit dem Meldedatum
arbeiten, weil das jetzt unabhängig von Meldeverzögerung und Testdauer und so ist, das heißt.
Das ist ein bisschen präziser. Ich meine, ist jetzt auch nicht völlig frei von Wochentagsschwankungen, aber
Es äh ist halt schon ein bisschen besser. Also man ist halt ein bisschen näher dran, aber das Problem ist
Es gibt halt für das Meldedatum in dem Sinne dann keine Stichtags äh Regelung ähm.
Wenn man das nach Meldedatum macht, weil wie gesagt, für ein bestimmtes Meldedatum halt Sachen noch nachkommen können werden. Wenn man's nach Veröffentlichungsdatum macht.
Ist veröffentlicht, ist veröffentlicht. So, dann ist halt klar, an dem Tag gab's so und so viel neue Infektionen,
so und es wird immer an dem Tag so und so viel neue Infektionen gegeben haben oder.
Und so viel Neuinfektionen wurden gemeldet, so wie man das eigentlich normalerweise erwartet, aber eben
Gesundheitswesen, auch so bei Sterbefällen oder so ist man's halt gewohnt irgendwie ein Jahr lang Daten zu sammeln und dann irgendwann, wenn die dann eintreffen, so Februar, März, April setzen sich dann die Leute dran und fangen an zu rechnen
damit.
Aber dieser ganze Real Time Betrieb des überfordert quasi diese Strukturen.
Ja das also diese Real Time Bericht Geschichte.
Ist halt gegengesetzt zu dem, was man in normalen Zeiten mit normalen Krankheiten in nicht Pandemiesituationen so eigentlich an Berichterstattung braucht.
Ja. Also um vielleicht da an der Stelle die Terminologie auch nochmal klar zu machen, weil wir hatten das ja auch letzte Woche schon angesprochen und mich haben auch ein paar Leute etwas verwirrt, nachgefragt, weil ihnen das irgendwie nicht klar war. Mit Meldedatum meinen wir,
Wann wird ein Fall, wenn jetzt ein positiver Test vorliegt, ja? Sagen wir mal, ihr werdet jetzt getestet bei irgendeinem Labor.
Wann liegt diese Information eines positiven Tests dem Gesundheitsamt vor.
Nein, beziehungsweise eigentlich ist das Meldedatum, dass äh äh wann sagen der erste Kontakt mit dem Gesundheitsamt war, oder?
Der erste Kontakt mit dem Gesundheitsamt, ne? Das ist doch im Prinzip der erste Kontakt mit dem Gesundheitsamt, oder?
Also es kann halt in beide Richtungen gehen, natürlich es kann sein, nur es wird ein Test gemacht und dann wird's seit dem Gesundheitsamt gemeldet oder es kann halt sein,
ja, dass du das Gesundheitsamt kontaktierst, um dann anschließend einen Test zu machen.
Aber das dürfte doch die die große Ausnahme sein. Wer kontaktiert den schon direkt irgendwie jetzt das Gesundheitsamt.
Na ja, wenn äh.
Alles eines Tracings, das ist Gesundheitsamt dich auffordert.
Zum Beispiel, ja. Oder ja.
Okay, gut, also dann formuliere ich es mal ein bisschen anders.
Du als Fall, wenn du das äh du als Fall, dem Gesundheitsamt das erste Mal irgendwie gewahr wirst.
Ja, das kann der Zeitpunkt sein, wo das Labor einen positiven Test meldet oder unter Umständen auch schon ein paar Tage vorher, weil es irgendwie Kontakt gab in dem Zusammenhang, der dann später in einen Fall kam.
Das ist das Meldedatum. Ne?
Damit liegt diese Information bei einem von vierhundert Gesundheitsämtern in Deutschland vor. So die permanent halt arbeitet und Daten akkumuliert und Dinge korrigiert und rumtelefoniert und hast nicht gesehen
was weiß ich, wie viel Faxe äh verschickt und irgendwie das auf Papier schreibt und dann wieder in Computer eintippt, ausdruckt und dann wieder abtippt, weiß ich alles,
auf jeden Fall dauert es dann eine Weile bis diese,
Daten natürlich letzten Endes beim RKI, also der zentralen Behörde für alle Gesundheitsämter im Falle des Infektionsschutzes
ankommt und wenn das RKI diese Daten erhält, dann gelten sie als veröffentlicht.
Genau, also die die Gesundheitsämter selbst sammeln,
Daten, so geben die ein, die haben halt verschiedene IT-Systeme, gibt da ich.
Weiß nicht genau, wie viel drei, vier, fünf verschiedene Arten von IT-Systemen, manche Bundesländer haben das Gleiche, äh andere haben halt ein anderes Produkt und andere wieder was Selbstgebautes äh und so,
und da sammeln die erstmal selber die Daten und teilweise war's dann halt so, dass
in Hamburg das Ganze morgens passiert ist
und dann wurden die Daten übermittelt und das RKI nimmt aber noch Daten entgegen bis vermute mal Mitternacht. Also alles was bis Mitternacht da ist
irgendwie diese Meldungen sind jetzt da und dann werden die halt verarbeitet und dann sind die Zahlen für den Tag da. Ja und.
Wenn natürlich mir Gesundheitsamt selber die Daten erst abends zusammenzählt und die Daten vom Abend übermittelt äh.
Sind die Daten natürlich im Endeffekt einen Tag schneller da, als wenn das Gesundheitsamt des Morgens macht.
Morgens liegen halt in der Regel nur die Daten vom Vortag vor. Also so können dann halt schon so kleine organisatorische.
Änderungen oder Abläufe halt ähm ja die Verzögerung äh erhöhen.
Trotzdem gab's immer mal wieder Fälle, wo diese Veröffentlichung sehr viel später stattgefunden hat. Also eine milde.
Verzögerung, das ist insofern etwas ähm deiner Tabelle, sprichst du ja von einer Meldungsverzögerung.
Wenn man jetzt mal das Wörtlich nehmen und das Bildedatum ist beim Gesundheitsamt und das Veröffentlichungsdatum ist es beim RKI, dann ist es ja eigentlich eher eine Veröffentlichungsverzögerung, oder?
Ja, also zwischen Meldung beim Gesundheitsamt, ja, ja, wäre wahrscheinlich könnte man's so nennen, nachdem wer wem was meldet, also eigentlich meldet.
Genau, ich versuche da nur grad eine klare äh eine klare Temmologie hinzubekommen, die nicht weiter verwirrt und äh insofern,
ist äh was in der Tabelle derzeit steht mit Meldeverzögerung meint, die Differenz zwischen Meldung beim Gesundheitsamt und Veröffentlichung gegenüber dem RKI.
Genau und da gibt's jetzt auch eine neue Spalte.
Dachte irgendwie, wenn ich schon sowieso Mittelwert und medial und standardabweichung nehme, weil ich halt gleich auch noch das Minimum und das Maximum dabei äh packen äh und was sich dort auch geändert hat, ist,
dass sich das Ganze jetzt immer nur auf die Fälle des aktuellen Tages auch bezieh,
ja? Das heißt, du kannst halt jetzt sagen, die Fälle, die heute gemeldet wurden, haben im,
Mittelwert sechs Komma vier Tage zwischen Meldung beim Gesundheitsamt und Veröffentlichung durchs RKI. Also die Älteste, die,
Lieferung, die kam aus Nordrhein-Westfalen. Heute, die ist dreihundertzweiundfünfzig Tage alt, ja.
Also da liegen,
Ja, da hat's jemand vor dreihundertzweiundfünfzig Tagen irgendwie beim Amt gemeldet und daraus ist jetzt ein Fall geworden. Das können halt auch Updates.
Sein irgendwie weiß ich nicht, aber noch eigentlich äh ähm.
Irgendwelche Korrekturen von irgendwas.
Ja
Ja, ja, also eigentlich nehme ich aus der Statistik die Negativfälle raus, weil das ist klar, wenn dann irgendwelche Stornos kommen oder so, sind das keine neuen Fälle, deswegen.
Sind das eigentlich nur sagen jetzt neue Fälle in dem Sinne, da ist jemand irgendwie vor dreihundertsiebenunddreißig Tagen angeblich äh kann man nämlich auch eine Fehlfehleingabe sein.
Ja. Und das Minimum ähm wollte ich nicht nochmal anzeigen, weil das Minimum ist äh nämlich dasselbe, was in der Spalte letzte Zählung steht, ja.
Okay, das ist jetzt der Nördich. Auf jeden Fall viele viele Felder, äh viele Informationen
und ähm das ist halt alles dafür gedacht, nicht unbedingt, dass man sie jetzt vielleicht diese Spalten permanent ähm,
schaut's an, es ist eben so ein bisschen so ein Debagging, wenn irgendwas unklar ist, dann kann man an diesen Spalten manchmal sehen, was äh eigentlich aus dem Ruder läuft und oder das etwas aus dem Ruder läuft, was
uns dann auch immer wieder auf neue Sachen gebracht hat im letzten Jahr.
Ja. Ansonsten gibt's bei den Todesfällen noch eine neue Spalte, die halt die Fallsterblichkeit äh anzeigt. Die Case Fatality Racio.
Was ich halt auch ganz.
Interessant fand und das natürlich später dann vor allen Dingen auch nach Altersgruppen und so äh und für verschiedene Landkreise.
Dann kommt. Aber im Moment ist halt für kann man halt Landkreise und Länder vergleichen, äh wie viele äh dort sagen von den.
Gemeldeten Fällen bisher verstorben sind.
Zwo Komma acht sieben Prozent für Deutschland. Zwo Komma acht sieben Prozent aller gemeldeten Fälle sind dann äh die Leute gestorben.
Und ja in manchen Bundesländern bis zu vier, also in Sachsen bis zu sind's waren's sogar vier Prozent.
Bremen zwei interessant.
Na ja, also es ist halt schon so, wenn man anfängt auf die Bundesländer oder auf die Kreise zu gucken, dass dann.
So bestimmte Kennzahlen doch sehr stark variieren können. Und wenn man dann,
Deutsche Zahlen mit Auslandszahlen vergleich hast du halt oft Länder dabei, die kleiner sind als viele deutsche Bundesländer, ja ähm und ähm insofern.
Ja ist es dann schon auch manchmal ganz erhellend zu gucken, wie sich den überhaupt die Bundesländer unterscheiden und
manches Ausland unterscheidet sich dann weniger von Deutschland als manches Bundesland so bei bestimmten äh Kennzahlen.
Du hast ja jetzt auch ähm.
Neu in der Datenbasis, auch wenn sich das jetzt in dieser Tabelle derzeit noch nicht niederschlägt, ja im Hintergrund auch noch an der Alters äh Gruppenstatistik gearbeitet. Das ist jetzt so quasi noch ein ungehobener Schatz. Wir werden aber über bestimmte Erkenntnisse äh jetzt auch schon nochmal sprechen
heute hast du denn dann generell auch für jeden Landkreis so das Durchschnittsalter, wie alt die Leute da sind?
Das könnte man ja dann sozusagen bei der CFR noch mit äh einblenden sozusagen.
Ja, ja, klar. Ja, ja, das äh.
Also ob jetzt sagen wir mal, wenn Sachsen vier Prozent hat frage ich mich natürlich als erstes ist Sachsen jetzt älter.
Als die anderen Bundesländer oder oder korrigiert das jetzt irgendwie nicht miteinander, ne.
Ja, also ich berechne halt dann sowieso die Inzidenzen äh innerhalb der Altersgruppe äh.
Die sind normiert auf wie viele Leute gibt es in dieser Altersgruppe? Nicht wie viel Prozent von denen die erkrankt sind, waren sechzig, sondern wie viel von den Sechzigjährigen sind.
Erkranken.
Gut, dann werden wir noch drauf äh kommen. Auf jeden Fall, die Tabelle ist jetzt da äh für die Datenbastler unter euch, gibt es auch eine neue CSV-Datei, die jetzt sehr viel mehr Details enthält und du stellst auch noch die,
CSV-Variante mit äh allen Altersgruppen auch noch online, ne? Im ersten Schritt.
Ja, ähm, ich mein,
bin noch gerade ziemlich am Wurschteln und am am Umbauen. Also es sind kommen möglicherweise jetzt noch in den nächsten eins, zwei, drei Tagen noch größere Änderungen
aber es sollte sich dann wieder hoffentlich langsam ein bisschen stabilisieren, also zumindest ist das Format
sollte sich stabilisieren und wenn das der Fall ist, dann kann man
mal ein bisschen äh wieder hier im im Detail beleuchten, was man denn dann mit den Dateien auch noch so alles selber anfangen,
kann, weil im Prinzip äh sind da nämlich unglaublich viele Spalten drin und man kann die dann halt sehr schnell mit irgendeiner Tabellenkalkulation auch aufmachen und sich da selber genau die Daten rausholen.
Die man gerne hätte. Und es ist dann alles schon vor vorberechnet und vorgekaut äh also fast zu viel, aber.
Ja, die hat irgendwie dreihundertdreißig Spalten mittlerweile, die große Tabelle.
Wow.
Ja, aber sind schon erste Sachen entstanden, auch also hier in dem äh Slackkanal hat der Björn zum Beispiel mal hier so einfach mal eine Deutschlandkarte gemalt, wo da sozusagen deine deine Risikofaktoren drin sind und so, also
das sind schon hat jetzt Potenzial für neue Einblicke und ich glaube, da werden wir in den nächsten Wochen noch eine ganze Menge Neuigkeiten haben.
Ja, also was mir so vorschwebt, ich dann bestimmte Zellen äh auswähle
in der Tabelle, dass ich mir dann halt in der Tabelle letztlich auswähle, äh was für eine Art von Zeitreihe äh ich miteinander vergleichen will, dass es sozusagen die Grundidee
dass die Tabelle quasi das Interface ist um mir meine Grafiken anzeigen zu lassen, spezielle Grafiken anzeigen zu lassen.
Ja
Gut, dann kommen wir jetzt erstmal zu den Zahlen jetzt in Bezug auf die Pandemie in Deutschland, was
können wir jetzt so herauslesen aus dem was das RKI neu gemeldet hat. Äh Deutschland, wie geht's uns denn heute.
Die Zahlen steigen wieder äh oder immer noch jetzt seit vier Wochen.
Nicht rasant so mit einem.
RWT, ja der sich so bewegt um also gerade um die eins Komma null fünf, also knapp über eins eigentlich die ganze Zeit.
Oder seit drei Wochen definitiv über eins.
Und ja schwankt ein bisschen, war mal fast auf eins wieder runter. So jetzt der sieben Tage RWT oder
jetzt für eine kurze Zeit berechnet hat, dann war es vielleicht sogar unter äh eins äh mal aber eigentlich der sieben Tage R Wert ist seit drei Wochen,
war eins und deswegen steigen halt die Zahlen und jetzt hatten wir.
Irgendwie auch zumindest einen Berliner Feiertag äh,
und ja dadurch dadurch gab's dann noch so ein so ein paar Ausreißer, aber insbesondere jetzt in den letzten beiden Tagen hat's halt ganz gut.
Zugelegt wieder also das hat jetzt.
Die Zahl der berichteten Neuinfektionen ganz gut hoch hochgetrieben.
Also ich vergleiche mal ganz gerne so diese Anstiegskurven mit der im äh mit den Anstiegskurven, die wir sie so vor der zweiten Welle gesehen haben, um mal so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wo wir uns da so Anstiegstech äh technisch zu befinden und das ist so September.
Ne, nur, dass wir halt auf einem sehr viel höheren Niveau äh uns äh ohnehin schon befunden haben, aber so von der von der Anstiegsdynamik her
ist es eben so, September, während's dann ja dann im Oktober schon richtig angefangen hat zu knallen. Das heißt jetzt nicht unbedingt, dass das jetzt so passieren muss. Wir haben ja jetzt auch noch viele andere Faktoren, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass wir da jetzt ein besonders,
beruhigendes Geschehen hätten, so das könnte schon auch noch ausreißen.
Die Vorhersagen von den meisten gehen auch in diese Richtung.
Ja. Also tatsächlich so hatte ich erwartet, dass.
Wir erstmal so ein längeres Plateau durchlaufen beziehungsweise, dass sich die Rückgänge erstmal verlangsamen werden, bis es sich dann umkehrt, aber stattdessen kam's halt irgendwann,
so vor vier Wochen äh zu einem apropten Halt. Die Zahlen gingen nicht mehr weiter runter.
Und äh fing dann an relativ forsch äh wieder hochzugehen. Äh so dass ich erstmal dachte, upsa, das hatte ich jetzt nicht erwartet, dass das jetzt so schnell
die Trendwende und dann,
hatte sich, er hatte es sich aber erstmal wiederum verlangsamt, weil er hatte, okay, jetzt ist die Trendwende aber ziemlich schnell da, jetzt ähm,
ja, könnte das wieder in äh einen massiven Anstieg umschlagen,
ist es aber erstmal oder noch nicht jedenfalls, aber wie du richtig sagst, das kann halt jetzt jeden Tag
passieren oder jede äh oder es, wenn dann ist es schon möglicherweise passiert und
Es ist uns halt noch nicht aufgefallen, wir haben's noch nicht gezählt, aber nach die letzten beiden Tage waren etwas unschön und die Zahlen.
Jedenfalls deutschlandweit.
Ja, bei den Todeszahlen wiederum sieht's anders aus.
Ja die, ja.
Haben wir auch schon ein bisschen mit gerechnet.
Auch die fallen halt erstmal noch weiter so und da kommen wahrscheinlich im Moment zwei Dinge zusammen oder was da.
Ganz klar dahinter steckt ist 'ne fallende Institz bei den Alten die halt extrem in den Keller.
Gegangen ist, das ist der der Haupthintergrund, das heißt es infizieren sich jetzt im Verhältnis deutlich.
Weniger alte gerade und.
Das zeigt sich, ne? Aber grundsätzlich wäre da gäbe es jetzt keine Impfung.
Dann würden wir jetzt erwarten, dass die Todeszahlen jetzt auch mit ansteigen, weil die Infektionszahlen vor vier Wochen sich umgedreht.
Das heißt, jetzt ist eigentlich genau ab dieser Woche kann man sagen, wird man das erste Mal sehen, wie sich die Impfungen real niederschlagen.
Ja
Man kann's jetzt schon ahnen anhand der Infektionszahlen, aber bei den Todeszahlen sehen wir es halt frühestens jetzt.
Mal, wenn man sich das so so anschaut.
Sind es halt immer so eigentlich eher zwei Wochen Verzögerung zwischen Gipfel an Infektionsmeldungen und Gipfel an Todesmeldungen, ja. Kannst du.
Zu. Das heißt, wenn du, wenn du halt genau hinguckst, siehst du halt auch vor zwei Wochen so ein kleines Plateau, da ist es halt nicht weiter zurückgegangen.
Mein man kann's jetzt nicht, ich muss es jetzt nicht überinterpretieren, weil das sind alles sehr kleine Effekte, es kann auch Zufall sein, aber es würde halt passen.
Aber danach ging's halt weiter runter.
Okay, zwei Wochen klingt äh plausibel, das heißt es kann sein, dass wir die Effekte schon sehen. So, also äh.
Macht ganz den Eindruck, dass dass da auf jeden Fall eine Trendwende bei den Sterbezahlen schon erkennbar ist.
Wie hat sich denn das Test geschehen? Jetzt äh entwickelt.
Ja, bei den Tests ist nichts Spektakuläres passiert. So die.
Positivquote, das ist das Entscheidende ist halt,
ganz leicht angestiegen, während die Zahl der Tests ganz leicht gefallen ist, aber eigentlich.
Das normale wöchentliche Schwankungen bei der bei der Zahl der Tests, die liegen halt immer irgendwie zwischen ein ein und eins Komma zwei Millionen irgendwo.
Geht das hin und her und äh ja also.
Die Testzahlen sagen nur, es gab keine großen Änderungen im Testregime oder bei der Anzahl.
Der Tests, die wir jetzt berücksichtigen müssten, äh wenn wir die Zahlen interpretieren dann gerade.
Aber die positiven Quote ist weiter leicht gestiegen.
Ja ganz leicht gestiegen. Mhm.
Und wenn man sich das jetzt so im Plot anschaut, dann kann halt sehen, okay, äh so wie die Infektionszahlen.
Gehen auch die positiven Quote in so ein, so ein Knick, das heißt so der der Absturz ist abgefangen worden oder anders ausgedrückt, auch da könnte sich im Prinzip diese dritte Welle andeuten.
Auch wenn der Betrachtungszeitraum jetzt da noch zu gering ist, aber wie schön die positiven Quote generell dem Infektionsgeschehen folgt, das hatten wir ja hier schon mal angemerkt und das zeigt sich halt auch an dieser Stelle. Also,
bevor auch dieser Wert nicht in den Keller geht, kann man hier keinerlei Entwarnung geben.
Ja im Gegenteil ähm insbesondere
Ja, wir hatten ja auch das das Thema Dispersion schon mal ganz früh, nämlich die die Frage, wie viele Leute stecken eigentlich äh wie viele an und äh,
wie verbreitet es jetzt äh sowas und wie sehr.
Bringt das auch quasi einen Zufall äh in in das Ganze Geschehen rein.
Sodass äh wenn du Pech hast und du hast irgendwo, weiß nicht, zwei, drei Supersprayer oder wenn ich sage mal.
Wahrscheinlich, so wie es ist, ungefähr zehn Prozent der Leute für achtzig Prozent der Infektionen äh zuständig sind. Also zehn Prozent der der Infizierten ähm.
Ja plus dass es halt.
Auch unterschiedlich viele Verbindungen zwischen verschiedenen Gegenden von von Deutschland gibt und.
Im Effekt kann's dann sein, dass irgendwo
in irgendeinem bestimmten Milieu oder in irgendeiner geografischen Gegend. Das Ganze jetzt erstmal hochkocht
und dann äh da noch nicht so richtig ausbrechen äh kann, so aber irgendwann bricht es dann vielleicht aus äh so oder äh reißt's dann irgendwo hin und dann.
Mit ein bisschen Pech sage ich mal, äh kann plötzlich das Infektionsgeschehen irgendwo in die Höhe gehen, ohne dass du,
wirklich einen klaren Grund dafür ausmachen kannst, warum es jetzt äh dort vielleicht gerade steigt oder auch umgekehrt, warum irgendwo gerade etwas nicht steigt, weil ich, ja
keine Ahnung ähm man trifft sich nur noch mit den Leuten hm,
die man sowieso kennt und macht keine neuen Freunde, geht eh nicht aus und ja und irgendwie alle die das tun haben sich schon mal durchinfiziert die ganzen Unvorsichtigen und die Vorsichtigen so
passen jetzt halt auf und infizieren sich nicht. So, das kann halt auch ein Effekt sein.
Und natürlich der Einfluss der neuen Varianten
die ja im Prinzip jetzt auch äh uns dazu bringen, vielleicht auf die ganze Pandemie als zwei Pandemien gleichzeitig zu schauen, wo wir eben ganz unterschiedliche Aus,
Patterns haben, ne? Während also der Wildtyp überall steckt,
halt die Variante zunächst einmal erstmal da, wo sie frisch eingetragen wurde und braucht eben eine Weile, bis sie sich gleichmäßig verbreitet und während sie halt an manchen Stellen schon wütet
ähm ist dann der selbe Anstieg nicht unbedingt linear überall so zu sehen, bis dann eben irgendwann auch das dann sich weiter verbreitet.
Ja, man kann wahrscheinlich sagen, langfristig ist es dann,
schon entscheidend, was du tust und wie du dich schützt, aber kurz und mittelfristig kannst da offensichtlich Verzögerungen.
Geben. Ähm bei der Ausbreitung.
Ein anderes Ding, das hatten wir auch schon mal thematisiert. Ich glaube, dass die B eins eins sieben Variante äh was.
Die ähm,
erhöhte Ansteckungsrate angeht, ihr sich am unteren Ende der bisherigen Schätzungen bewegt, nämlich,
also zumindest wegen das die letzten Zahlen aus England nahe, was sich da entnommen habe, dreißig Prozent,
mehr im Durchschnitt bei Kindern vierzig Prozent. So, komischerweise.
Die ursprüngliche Befürchtung ging ja bis zu sechzig, siebzig Prozent.
Fünfzig, sechzig, siebzig Prozent. Ich ich hatte jetzt nie für ganz so hoch gehalten, da habe ich auch gesagt, weil sonst hm wären halt,
die sinkenden Zahlen in England nicht so äh zu erklären gewesen, wenn das wirklich jetzt so der absolute Superbuck.
Wäre äh aber dreißig bis vierzig Prozent bei Kindern sind halt auch schon natürlich schlimm genug, das heißt ähm
dass du, wenn die neue Variante kommt
wenn du vorher mit der alten Variante einen R-Wert von null Komma neun hattest oder null Komma acht, dann liegt der halt hinterher bei hundert Prozent eben ja,
über eins und die Zahlen steigen an. Ähm.
Auf der anderen Seite ja wird's natürlich jetzt wärmer, mh so dass das drück.
Wiederum ein bisschen auf den Erde aber das sind halt auch alles jetzt so nicht lineare Effekte. Man kann zwar ungefähr sagen ja ähm,
Es ist wird besser, je wärmer und sonniger, es wird, aber.
Wie groß die Auswirkung es wissen noch nicht. Nur wenn's jetzt tatsächlich die dreißig Prozent sind bei B eins eins sieben bedeutet das,
dass wir schon eigentlich eine ganz gute Chance haben oder gehabt hätten, die Zahlen runterzukriegen, muss man jetzt sagen.
Und die Öffnungen bisher haben ja einen geringeren Beitrag.
Zum Wachstum geleistet oder praktisch fast gar nicht, also er ist im Moment gar nicht erkennbar.
Eigentlich oder vielleicht von null Komma null fünf bis also fünf bis zehn Prozent auf den auf den R äh Füller, ich bisher Lockerungsbedingt und weiteres,
fünfzehn Prozent eben durch die Verbreitung der der neuen Mutante. So.
Ja, schauen wir mal. Ich meine, Schulen sind jetzt seit zwei Wochen am Start.
Ja? Das heißt äh das Ergebnis davon werden wir jetzt erst sehen. Da wir jetzt schon über die Varianten gesprochen haben und B eins eins sieben ähm um nachher nicht zu viel zu springen.
Es gibt ja,
starke Zahlen aus Schweden, es gibt ähnliche Beobachtungen auch in UK, in Italien, in Frankreich, überall gehen
die Infektionszahlen anteilig für die niedrigsten Altersgruppen deutlich nach oben.
Und das ist ja auch etwas, was du auch in den deutschen Zahlen jetzt herauslesen kannst mit dem neuen Datenmodell.
Hier. Ja. Genau.
Kann man das dann für Deutschland auch schon sehen.
Ja und zwar sehen wir eigentlich seit dem zwanzigsten zweiten.
Ja, also das jetzt ungefähr seit drei Wochen oder ja vor drei Wochen.
Waren die Institzen in den Altersgruppen von hm es ist null bis fünf und von.
Fünf bis vierzehn waren halt ja extrem.
Niedrig so, also die niedrigsten Institutionen in allen Altersgruppen überhaupt und seitdem sind die beiden,
deutlich nach oben marschiert, haben sich ja nicht ganz verdoppelt, aber fast verdoppelt.
Ja, seit dem zwanzigsten, also innerhalb von jetzt drei Wochen ungefähr eine Verdopplung bei den Kindern.
Und ähm während bei den achtzig Plus, wie er in dem selben Zeitraum.
Fast eine Halbierung, also mehr als eine Drittlung gesehen haben, so die laufen, also komplett.
Auseinander und bei den anderen, bei den mittleren Altersgruppen gibt's halt einen leichten Anstie.
Also wir werden die Grafik auch in unserem Blog in den Shownotes haben, wenn man sich das so anschaut, gerade jetzt das Geschehen in den letzten
vier Wochen, dann ist das schon drastisch, ne? Also Ü achtzig war ganz klar im Dezember ja im Dezember einfach.
Über alles, ja, es ist einfach der.
Ja, also es hat also alles andere massiv überstrahlt und ist dann im Zuge der äh Impfung ungefähr.
Dem wann geht das hier los? Ja ab Januar, ab zweite Woche Januar ging's dann, ging dann einfach eine eine Talfahrt, die bis jetzt anhält.
Runter, ja? Bis auf fünfzig, also sozusagen hat sich dann von dreihundertfünfzig auf fünfzig im Faktor sieben abgesenkt,
Und ja und wird jetzt nahezu von allen anderen Altersgruppen überholt. Das Einzige, was jetzt noch äh da mithalten kann, ist halt sechzig bis neunundsiebzig,
hoffen wir mal, dass auch dort jetzt demnächst die Impfung dazu kommen, aber man kann jetzt schon mal festhalten, infizieren, tun sich.
Nur noch die Jüngeren.
Oder ausbreiten tut es sich äh jetzt unter den Jüngeren und sagen je je jünger umso stärker breitet es sich gerade aus so ungefähr.
Genau, also wenn sich der Trend so abzeichnet, kippt das sozusagen einfach alles komplett rum, ne? Also dieser alte Sicht auf die Geschichte. Kinder haben ja mit dieser Pandemie nichts zu tun und es betrifft ja nur die Älteren.
Das ist jetzt einfach genau andersrum durch einerseits die neue Virusmutante andererseits durch die äh durch die Impfung.
Aber na ja, ich gucke, sonst war die Institanzentwicklung, also es gab wenig Momente, wo.
Wie sich mal äh zwei Institzen in verschiedenen Altersgruppen gekreuzt haben, sondern normalerweise,
verlaufen, die so ein bisschen als als paralleles Bündel und da ist es definitiv vor zwei, drei Wochen ist irgendwas passiert, weil wir jetzt.
Gerade ganz viele Kreuzungseffekte haben.
Die Karten werden neu gemischt.
Also genau, was immer ihr bisher über die Pandemie gehört oder gewusst habt. Es stimmt alles nicht, es ist alles anders jetzt. Seit zwei Wochen.
Nicht natürlich nicht wirklich, aber ja, diese Pandemie hält halt immer wieder Überraschungen,
Die ist echt fies. So, die schlägt halt nicht zu, wenn sie zuschlagen soll und dafür äh so, wenn sie eigentlich.
Dann runtergehen soll, dann ja tut sich's dann oft nicht.
Missachtet einfach unsere Ansagen. So ist das. Willst du jetzt nochmal was zu der Situation in Bundesländern äh sagen und,
dann können wir vielleicht danach zu den anderen Themen vorstoßen, aber dann haben wir diesen Zahlenteil vielleicht durch und dann müssen wir nochmal über Bielefeld reden.
Ja, gut bei den bei den Bundesländern sind halt Thüringen und Sachsen.
Ganz oben. So ich musste halt hatte mich halt entschieden gesagt die Hunderterschwelle auch noch einzubauen und die,
Programmcode,
haben die halt verschiedene ja verschiedene Namen so das unterste Side Condition safe so und dann geht's halt dann rot war halt bisher
Danger. So und äh ja und jetzt äh gibt's halt.
Auch alles über hundert ähm ist jetzt ähm Condition Ultra. So.
Okay.
Ultra. Genau und das sind halt jetzt die äh Violetten äh Violet-Hinterlegten und da sind eben Thüringen und Sachsen äh gerade Violett, weil sie halt.
Über hundert Liegen ähm ja hunderteinundfünfzig bei Thüringen, hundertzwei bei Sachsen, alle anderen. Dagegen.
Liegen.
Unter hundert und es gibt sogar zwei Schleswig-Holstein und das Saarland, die halt unter fünfzig liegen.
Pool, das ist halt ganz schön und der Rest sammelt sich so, ja, eben zwischen fünfzig.
Und hundert und Sachsen-Anhalt ist da äh knapp an der Grenze gerade und auch mit steigenden Zahlen und wird.
Also da auch nicht mehr lange Spaß haben und überhaupt bei den momentanen Trends werden.
Über die Hälfte der Landkreise, wenn sich der nicht ändern würde, so sind zwei Drittel der Landkreise über hundert in äh vier Wochen.
Und ja.
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern versucht ja, sich schon rauszumogeln, in dem sie sagen, na ja, nee, hundert gefällt uns eigentlich gar nicht, wenn nehmen mal zweihundert, erst dann ist es irgendwie ultra für uns. Ja.
Mhm. Äh ja, ja. Ja, so mach.
Wie vorausgesagt letzte Woche diese Lockerungsmaßnahmen, die an die Inzedenz gebunden sind von fünfzig bis hundert.
Ja oder auch unter, also unter fünfzig könnte zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt ausschließlich das Saarland und Schleswig-Holstein,
in Anspruch nehmen, nur,
In Schleswig-Holstein steigen die Zahlen und nur im Saarland fallen sie. Da fallen sie allerdings auch beträchtlich, muss man dazu sagen. Ja, also Saarland hat gerade mal ein Air von null Komma acht vier, das ist irgendwie ein sehr sauguter Wert und was mich auch völlig überrascht ist, dass auch Berlin,
so gut dasteht.
Besondere unser Bezirk. Wir sind ja gerade hier so im im ja weiß ich auch nicht, im Bezirk der Glückseligen,
mit, ne? Also Pankow hat da nochmal so ein richtig niedrigen Wert, ne? Ist richtig sehe.
Und guckt mal Shorts, aber ich glaube, in Berlin sind wir auf jeden Fall sind wir äh die Besten.
Und haben einen R von null Komma neun eins, das geht so und haben.
Ja neununddreißig neun als Institanz. Es kann sich doch sehen lassen.
Ja, ja, ja. Also, wir waren schon mal besser.
Ja wir werden alle schon mal besser, aber ich meine im im.
Ja, ja. Nein, man man ja.
Blinden haben wir ja zumindest noch ein Auge.
Ja, aber entscheidend ist es tatsächlich äh in den letzten sieben Tagen in allen Berliner Bezirken die Zahlen zurückgegangen.
Und ich kann mir das ehrlich gesagt nicht erklären.
Ja. Ähm.
Du äh irgendeine irgendein Erklärungsmuster, ich meine, wir sind ja nicht unbedingt dafür bekannt, jetzt irgendwie alles besser zu machen.
Ne? Das ist nur das, was ich sagte, der Virus äh macht, was er will.
So, es werden natürlich viele kommen. Ei Haare ist ja klar, es wird ja warm, es ist ja jetzt der Sommer und die Sonne und deswegen so mag der Virus das nicht, aber äh das ist auch.
Keine Erklärung dafür, so. Also.
Eine Spekulation äh war jetzt noch das möglicherweise B eins eins sieben.
Halt andere Saisonalität hat äh als jetzt der der Wildtyp vielleicht, aber,
Dafür gibt es, wie gesagt, keinerlei,
Anzeichen, aber das Seltsame ist, dass wir quasi jetzt diesen Viruswechsel eigentlich durchführen, also jetzt umgesattelt sind oder die Infektion umgesattelt ist.
Was auch immer bezeichnend.
Auf eben diesen dann doch dreißig Prozent mindestens dreißig Prozent virulenteren Typ aber äh diese null Komma fünfzehn mehr sind halt grad nicht zu sehen.
An der Stelle müssen wir auch nochmal einen kleinen Nachtrag äh liefern, ähm bezüglich Änderungen in der Tabelle.
Du hattest ja erst vor Kurzem mal so zwei Spalten eingefügt, wo so deine deine Traumzustände abgebildet sind und wann man die denn erreicht, ja? Also,
Vergleich zur ersten Welle, wo wir es ja geschafft haben durch den Lokdown, die Institenz bis auf sieben runterzubringen, eine Zahl, die einem schon vollkommen unwirklich vorkommt, beziehungsweise in der Folge dann sogar
äh bis drei bis dann halt wieder der normale Sommer eingeleitet wurde äh da gab's jetzt
bis vor kurzem eine entsprechende Berechnungsspalte, wie lange es denn dauern würde, wenn man da landet. Das waren aber alles völlig utopische Zahlen. Jetzt hast du es halt genau auf die aktuelle Diskussion befindlichen fünfzig und einhundert als Ziel
angesetzt, das heißt, man kann halt jetzt sehen, okay, wenn es sich so weiterentwickelt, wie es sich jetzt gerade entwickelt, wo sind wir denn in vier Wochen äh beziehungsweise
In acht Wochen einerseits oder anders. Wie lange dauert es, bis wir bei fünfzig sind oder wie lange
zurückliegt das äh und entsprechend bei einer Institenz von einhundert, wenn man das jetzt mal auf Berlin übersetzt, dann würde das jetzt gerade bedeuten. Berlin hat eine Institution von einundsechzig drei, hat einen R von null Komma acht sieben.
Würde das so weiterlaufen, wären wir in vier Wochen bei dreiundzwanzig, neun, in acht Wochen, bei neun Komma drei. Also eigentlich paradiesische Zustände. Ja, oder anders ausgedrückt. Wir brauchen noch sechs Tage bis zu fünfzig und ähm,
Die hundert haben wir schon vor zwei Wochen verlassen sozusagen,
Das kann man da jetzt mal rauslesen aus so einer Minus fünfzehn, um mal so ein bisschen klarzumachen, wie man diese Zahlen lesen muss, ja, ne.
Also wenn der Wert positiv ist, heißt es, dass bei sagen gleichbleibendem Trend so bei gleichbleibenden R.
Die fünfzig oder die hundert erreicht wird.
Ist das ein Minuswert, heißt es, es geht in die falsche Richtung, also weg von der Grenze, sprich wenn ich über hundert bin,
es steigt, dann erreiche ich halt wieder die fünfziger noch die Hunderter Grenze, bin ich aber unter hundert, dann kann ich natürlich die Hundertergrenze bei fallenden Werten nicht erreichen, aber die Fünfziger und ja, so muss man das lesen.
Ja, du könntest die Zahlen noch einfärben, ne, weil das Beispiel ist gerade sehr gut, ne, weil die minus fünfzehn kann ja auch bedrohlich sein, aber in dem Fall ist sie ja positiv, ne? Als
es ist eigentlich eine grüne minus fünfzehn, weil sie sagt, wir haben die die hundert vor rechnerisch vor fünfzehn Tagen verlassen und das ist ja gut so, äh während es halt auch sein kann, wir erreichen sie nie
weil wir schon drüber sind. Also müsste man das nochmal in Relation setzen. Ach so viele Ideen, ne?
Was man nicht alles noch äh toller und besser machen könnte. Na gut.
Dann lass uns mal kurz auf diesen Aspekt dieser Saisonalität äh eingehen und äh was man denn vielleicht aus den Zahlen künftig, also aus diesen Neuaufbereiteten Zahlen deiner Risikotabelle. Lustiges äh rauslesen kann
In Zukunft oder vielleicht auch jetzt schon und zwar bin ich auf so ein Frett gestoßen. Ähm.
Fand ich ganz lustig, weil er sich ähm einerseits mit Bielefeld beschäftigt hat und andererseits äh mit einer
ja, eine Ausnahmesituation, weil wir hatten ja diesen Wintereinbruch vor ein paar Wochen.
Und das betraf ja die Mitte Deutschlands und den Westen nochmal sehr viel härter als hier zum Beispiel in Berlin.
Ich lese mal kurz diesen Trepp vor. Ähm kurz das Red über den möglichen Impact eines harten, kurzen Logdowns und die Möglichkeit von Zirokowit
schreibt dort äh Moment, wer schrieb äh Geheimrat äh Freakout
Und ähm genau, am sechsten zweiten, einundzwanzig ist ein Schneestumm über Ostwestfalen-Lippe gezogen. Der Schneefall hielt fast zwei Tage
an, böger, bis stürmischer Wind führte teils zu heftigen Schneeverwegungen. In der Folge ist in Bielefeld für mindestens sieben Tage fast der komplette ÖPNV ausgefallen. Kitas waren komplett
dicht. Viele Arbeitnehmer blieben teils einige Tage daheim, Autofahren war kaum möglich. Postpakete wurden nicht zugestellt, LKWs fuhren nicht
Bei eisigen Temperaturen gingen die Menschen stattdessen vor die Tür aufgrund des bögenen Windes und Temperaturen deutlich in den Minusgraden fand eine stabile Eirosolbildung kaum statt nach
knapp vierzehn Tagen war der Spuk vorbei, vor Frühling stand vor der Tür. In den letzten vierzehn Tagen ist die Institanz in Bielefeld plötzlich rapider,
gefallen, es wurden kaum noch Neuinfektionen gemeldet an einigen Tagen wurden gar keine Neuinfektion mehr gemeldet. Der prozentuale Anteil an Mutation liegt bei knapp dreißig Prozent. Tiefpunkt der Institenz waren am vierten und fünften dritten,
und so weiter. Also auf jeden Fall äh es geht hier noch ein bisschen weiter. Ich will euch jetzt nicht mit den ganzen Details äh nerven. Der Link ist drin. Tatsache ist
Am sechsten zweiten hat Bielefeld heftiges Ausnahmewetter.
Erwischt und ist förmlich eingefroren in seinen Aktivitäten. Ja und das äh hat uns mal motiviert mal.
Die Daten reinzuschauen, ob man denn da irgendwas rauslesen kann. Kann man da irgendwas rauslesen.
Ja was sagtest du? Wann war es so richtig kalt.
Also sechster, zweiter ging der Schneesturm los und der Schneefall hielt fast zwei Tage lang an.
So und das war dann für sieben Tage komplett der ÖPNV ausgefallen. Alle Kitas dicht,
Viele Arbeitnehmer blieben zu Hause, Autofahren war kaum möglich. Keine LKWs pa.
Gestellt und so weiter. Also eine Woche so richtig und nach vierzehn Tagen war dann der Spuk vorbei, dann ging die Temperaturen wieder hoch,
Also der Zeitraum vom sechsten zweiten bis zum zwanzigsten zweiten ist so der Betrachtungszeitpunkt.
Und dann müsste man aber.
Noch ein bisschen Verzögerung reinrechnen.
Gucken zwar eigentlich zwei Wochen Verzögerung reinrechnen. Gut, was man auf jeden Fall erstmal feststellen kann ist.
Des Bielefeld 'ne deutlich über der deutschen und auch über der Berliner.
Höhe liegende Institz hatte, also so die gingen dann fast bis dreihundert, also zweihundertachtzig in der Spitze, sieben Tage Institut.
Aber ist dann sehr schnell dann vom Höhepunkt.
Äh ziemlich rasch gefallen äh dann und zwar unter deutsches und berliner Niveau.
Aber äh diese Dynamik.
Herrschte dort schon vor diesem Kälteeinbruch. Was man so ein bisschen sieht, ist es mitten im,
Kälteeinbruch die Zahlen,
tatsächlich auf einen absoluten Tiefststand äh erreicht haben, weil ich gehe mal davon aus, dass wenn die Leute äh
nicht wirklich raus konnten. Viele auch gar nicht zum Gesundheitsamt sind oder viele Dienste äh oder zum Arzt oder wie auch immer, so. Das heißt, wir haben da eine Delle und.
Als es dann wärmer wird.
Gehen unmittelbar dann die Zahlen so ein bisschen hoch. Das spricht dafür, dass es da quasi so einen Nachholeffekt gab
in der Zeit und äh dann sind sie wieder runtergegangen,
so insofern würde ich sagen äh ja gibt es definitiv eine Anomalie.
Und die hat auch dazu geführt hm dass jetzt Bielefeld deutlich unter Berliner und Bundesdurchschnitt,
gelandet ist gerade. Also die hat wahrscheinlich geholfen äh Bielefeld noch ein bisschen weiter nach unten zu drücken, sonst wären die wahrscheinlich äh ja ein bisschen höher ausgetoppt,
Stimmst du da mit meiner Analyse überein.
Also von den ähm.
Auswertungen, die ich jetzt von dir hier bekommen habe, was auch was anderes, kann ich jetzt äh so recht nicht blicken. Äh auf jeden Fall. Also es ist ganz klar zu sehen, dass ab dem sechsten, also es
wie du schon sagtest, es ging schon vorher runter, aber es war ja dann vielleicht auch schon bevor der große Schneefall kam, hat es sich ja sozusagen angekündigt,
und ähm danach ging's auf jeden Fall deutlich runter.
Du hast ja auch noch so eine Auswahl, äh du hast ja auch noch so eine Auswertung nach äh den Altersgruppen gemacht. Das fand ich auch noch ganz interessant.
In äh in Folge dieser Kältephase merkt man, dass dass die Infektion bei den Alten stark zurückgegangen sind.
Ob das daran liegt, dass sie selber weniger unterwegs waren oder ob die dann seltener besucht wurden? Kann ich nicht sagen. Aber da ist schon so ein Knick, ne? Und äh der fällt halt bei den äh Älteren dann deutlicher aus als bei den anderen.
Ja und es sieht so aus, als wenn die Kids nicht raus aus dem Haus äh gedürft.
Irgendwie also die fünf bis Vierzehnjährigen hatten zufällig genau.
Derzeit äh sagen, also mit der mit der entsprechenden Meldeverzögerung so äh eine Institanz in der Nähe von fast null, also einstellig irgendwie.
Ja also in Bielefeld hat dann dieser Kälteeinbruch auf jeden Fall ganz schön was durcheinander gewirbelt.
Ja, das wird nochmal ganz lustig, wenn man die Daten dann äh später vielleicht auch wirklich mal mit Wetterdaten äh versuchen zu korrigieren, ne?
Gut, ich will das jetzt gar nicht weiter äh strapazieren, aber vielleicht noch eine Meldung, die ich ganz interessant fand in diesem Zusammenhang, weil ja so Saisonalität ist ja so, ne? Also Auswirkung des Wetters ist einfach ein Thema
und da gab's dann äh bei der Tagesschau noch die Meldung, das bezieht sich hier auch auf eine
Studie von Forschern der technischen Universität München und Helmholtz-Zentrum München
die Meinung sind, dass stärkere Pollenflug jetzt im Frühling.
Äh gegebenenfalls die Zahl der Corona-Virusinfektionen nach oben treiben kann.
Und zwar haben die sich halt ähm Daten äh angeschaut
äh an Orten ohne Lokdown Regelungen stieg die Infektionsrate im Schnitt um vier Prozent, wenn sich die Anzahl der Pollen in der Luft um hundert pro Kubikmeter erhöhte
Ja, also sie haben sich sozusagen Bereiche angeschaut mit Lokdown Regelungen und ohne und ähm haben halt irgendwie versucht, das miteinander in Korrelation zu bringen, ne. In manchen deutschen Städten seien im Buch Untersuchungszeitraum zeitweise pro Tag bis zu fünfhundert Pollen auf einen Kubikmeter gekommen. Dabei stiegen die Infektionsraten um mehr als
zwanzig Prozent.
Ja gab es aber in den Gebieten Lokdown Regelungen, halbierte sich die Zahl der Infektionen im Schnitt äh zu der äh Pollenkonzentration, ja?
Und es gibt da verschiedene Erklärungen dafür, also einerseits, wenn Pollen fliehen reagiert, die Körperabwehr in abgeschwächter Form auf Viren der Atemwege.
Weil die sich dann irgendwie mehr auf diese Pollen konzentrieren oder davon entsprechend beeinflusst werden. Das habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden.
Oder vielleicht nicht unnötig irgendwie Stress machen äh wollen, weil die.
So eine Reduktions äh so.
Runterfährt, damit. Mhm.
Genau, so kann man das auch lesen.
Genau. Der Körper produziert weniger antivirale Interviero, also das Prinzip fällt da so ein bisschen runter, um nicht zu überreagieren. Das ist ja auch ein Problem, was viele Leute haben, dass er halt bei Pollenflug dann entsprechend äh reagieren, ne.
Ja, also äh könnte auf jeden Fall dann auch nochmal so ein Faktor werden, ne.
Sie haben also Daten aus hundertdreißig Regionen, aus rund einunddreißig Ländern auf fünf Kontinenten analysiert. Ne und mit demographischen Faktoren und Temperatur und so weiter alles irgendwie korrigiert.
In welchem Zeitraum.
Das ist ja letzter äh zwanzig zwanzig halt so in den entsprechenden Zeiträumen, wo Pollenflug in den jeweiligen Ländern war. Also Frühjahr zwanzig zwanzig irgendwie.
Ja. Na ja, für zwanzig einundzwanzig lässt sich da noch relativ wenig sagen. Das vielleicht mal so ein bisschen nebenbei.
Ja, was sind die Vorhersagen betrifft? Ähm weil wir haben uns jetzt auch relativ wenig geäußert so mit irgendwie was sind jetzt hier mit dritte Welle eigentlich, ne
weil wir haben ja immer noch so eine öffentliche Diskussion laufen. Die Politik habe ich so den Eindruck druckt sich so ein bisschen weg.
Weil die gerade mal äh
die Zeit nutzen wollen, mal zwischen zwei Ministerpräsidentenkonferenzen äh einfach auch mal das Thema äh zu wechseln, außerdem müssen sich ja gerade alle für Korruption verantworten, haben sie auch mal andere Sachen zu tun.
Äh die Wissenschaft ist allerdings immer noch kräftig dabei ähm.
Die These zu vertreten, dass wir halt ansteigende Zahlen haben werden. Was mir dann aufgefallen ist, ist, es gibt ja auch so eine Art Wettbüro im Internet.
Kann man so sagen, ne? Das äh wie heißt das so schön, EP Expert Crowdford-Casting-Performance-Board.
Und ähm du kanntest das schon, ne? Ich habe das irgendwie erst vor kurzem entdeckt.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Du kannst es noch nicht. Na ja auf jeden Fall äh ist das irgendwie so ein ein System, wo,
alle möglichen Vorcaster, ihre eigenen Abschätzungen abgeben können und Voraussagen machen können. Was sie denn denken, wie sich so die Pandemie so entwickelt, das heißt
die untersuchen alle ihre Daten unabhängig voneinander und geben dann halt so Tipps ab, wie es sich denn so ähm,
entwickelt und geben dann entsprechende Einschätzungen ab
So und dann kann man dann hier auf der Webseite sehen, was sie denn so meinen, wie denn das jetzt so in äh der nächsten Zeit abgeht. Da gibt's jetzt hier Auswertungen für Deutschland und für Polen, das scheint jetzt ein deutsch-polnisches,
Projekt äh im Wesentlichen zu sein. Zunächst einmal zumindest und äh ja, für Deutschland, wenn ich mir das so anschaue.
Sind so die Voraussagen alle bis auf eine alle ja doch alle bis auf einen sehen steigende Zahlen.
Stand achter, dritter zwanzig einundzwanzig, muss man sagen.
Und ja, was ich so gelesen habe, sind es sagen einmal menschliche äh.
Vorhersager, die sich, also wenn man sich da einfach hinsetzen und dann Daten hochladen, ein paar davon äh sind dann aber auch äh ja Maschinenlearning Systeme.
Ähm die halt sich die bisherigen Daten angucken und dann irgendwie trainiert werden und dann äh,
Vorher sagen ja könnte ich ja, ich habe bisher ja ein bisschen gezögert äh so, meine neuronalen Netze da an den Start,
zu bringen, aber ähm.
Ja, es wäre vielleicht auch ein Ding überlegen dann irgendwann hier äh so ja.
Da was zu lernen, aber was kann man denn aus den Zahlen lernen.
Alles eröffnen. Also ähm sagen wir so, was dann äh so ein trainiertes Netz macht ist. Es spuckt halt einfach Zahlen raus. Das sagt dir normalerweise nicht warum.
Klar, natürlich, aber die Frage ist ja immer, womit trainierst du es? Also was ist sozusagen deine verlässliche Wahrheit auf Basis, welcher Daten, ne? So und ich meine, du hast ja das eigentliche Geschehen da draußen, als Input hast du ja nicht, du hast ja eigentlich nur die Resultate.
Nee, nee, das ist halt schon ganz einfach. Du nimmst halt was weiß ich, bestimmte Zeiträume, äh nimmst du halt äh einfach als Trainingsdatensatz und dann andere Zeiträume äh ni.
Also ja, nimmst du dann auch zur Validierung so, die das Netz dann nicht gesehen hat,
und dann ja äh siehst du halt sagen vorher schon ob so sagen kannst, kannst es ja für die Vergangenheit ausprobieren, ob das mit den Daten der Vergangenheit dann die Zukunft richtig vorhergesagt,
hätte, ja.
Ja gut, aber du hast ja nicht alle Daten, die das beeinflussen, hast du ja nicht wirklich in diesem System, also wenn du die Zahlen, die du jetzt hast, das ist halt im Prinzip ja alles immer nur Resultate und du kannst ja aus Resultaten nicht irgendwie die Resultate der Zukunft vorhersagen.
Also ich meine gut man könnte halt einfach das Internet scrappen und die Nachrichtenseiten und dann äh halt äh ja äh das sozusagen mit dann halt den,
Nachrichtenseiten einfach äh äh korrelieren und dann guckt er sich an. So was kommen jetzt für Nachrichten und ja,
Ähm also das das geht alles,
so, das kann man halt halt super machen. Das einzige Problem ist, dass das halt äh dann in den Momenten immer bricht, wo sich die Regeln ändern.
Also ähm das ist dann so ein bisschen wie,
ja, wenn du versuchst ähm durchsetzen auf Rot und Schwarz im Casino und verdoppeln des Einsatzes äh,
irgendwie so eine so eine so eine Reihe zu fahren, aber irgendwann so ja irgendwann kippt's dann.
Dann halt um oder vor allem bei Börsen ist es äh so dass irgendeine neue Situation kommt in die Welt, die plötzlich das Geschehen anders beeinflusst, als es in der Vergangenheit,
V.
Davon sind wir ja voll davon, ne? Wahlen äh haben einen Einfluss, äh das Wetter mag einen Einfluss haben. Also zumindest so latschgel, ne
große Wintereinbruch und so weiter definitiv irgendwelche Auswirkungen gehabt hier in Europa und in USA auch
Texas vor allem, dann hast du äh natürlich so Faktoren wie Impfstoff verfüg
et cetera, ne? Erfolgt einer Impfkampagne, aber eben auch andere politische Entscheidung und deswegen habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass man jetzt hier mit einem Maschine Learning so out of the Blue gleich gute äh
Erfolge erzielt, also nicht nicht, dass äh ich bezweifeln würde, dass ich nicht irgendetwas unter Umständen ganz gut voraussagen lassen kann, aber ich glaube
dass das jetzt nicht einfach ist, weil du halt.
Noch mehr Gedanken darüber machen muss, was denn eigentlich deine Datenbasis ist. Diese Vermutung mit der Nachrichtenlage, das kann man daran mal verifizieren, ja? Man könnte sagen, okay, was waren denn hier irgendwie die Suchstrinks in der der Woche und
Wie korrigiert denn das, aber ob das dann eben auch in die Zukunft funktioniert, weiß ich.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, so äh also du wirfst da einfach alles an Daten äh rein,
auch die der Nachbarländer und die von China und also der ganzen Welt.
Wirfst du da da rein zum Beispiel, selbst wenn du nur Deutschland vorhersagen willst, weil ja ähm sagen auch die Entwicklung in Deutschland
von der Entwicklung in anderen Ländern
abhängen kann oder die Länder Entwicklung in anderen Ländern der Entwicklung in Deutschland vorausläuft. All das muss zu dem System gar nicht sagen, ja, sondern das erkennt dann eben durch das Training
erkennt es halt völlig von alleine, wovon das vermutlich abhängt. Ja.
Klar, dass es,
Das ist das, was Machine Learning macht. Trotzdem ist natürlich die Auswahl deiner Daten äh an der Stelle entscheidend, ja. Du kannst ja komplett irrelevante Daten nehmen und das System fängt an, sich daraus irgendwelche Regeln abzuleit.
Ja ja ab absolut.
Zahl der Gänseblümchen im Berliner Parks äh hat jetzt halt äh auf
auf die Pandemie dann halt keinen keinen Einfluss, aber mindestens das einzige ist, was äh das System lernt, dann versucht es halt die Züge herzustellen, wo keine sind, ne? Also Maschinenlearning hat auch so viele äh
Pitfalls, das finde ich immer wieder bemerkenswert. Äh hier hast du das gesehen vor ein paar Tagen ging das doch irgendwie rum.
Also auch so, wo es darum ging, so ein Schien-Learning auf Bildern und das das System soll dann irgendwie sagen, was ist denn das.
Und dann äh ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, was da abgebildet war. Auf jeden Fall hat das System richtig erkannt, was auf diesem Foto war und dann hat aber irgendjemand äh einfach so ein bisschen Tape.
Drauf geklebt und draufgeschrieben Tee und dann war das irgendwie Tee. So ja vollkommen egal was sonst noch so auf diesem Bild drauf war ne,
weil einfach dieses Modell vorher halt viel Dinge gesehen hat, die beschriftet sind und wenn da Tee drauf stand, war halt die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch. Also das das bricht relativ schnell auseinander, wenn das,
Modell nicht wirklich einen Bezug hat und deswegen
habe ich so meine Zweifel, dass das jetzt einfach wäre, hier relevanten Faktoren zu finden, die dann tatsächlich eine hohe Aussagekraft haben äh für die Zukunft
ne. Anyway. Auf jeden Fall könnt ihr euch mal angucken äh für Deutschland und Polen gibt's hier so ein bisschen das Race. Ich wollte ja eigentlich auch nur so ein bisschen darauf hinaus, dass es äh.
Will nicht sagen, Konsens gibt, aber es zeichnet sich ab, dass alle, die jetzt gerade mit wissenschaftlichem Blick auf diese Sache schauen oder auch mit einem mathematischen Blick,
eher skeptisch sind, dass wir fallende Zahlen in absehbarer Zeit sehen werden.
Mhm. Und die KIs führen auch nicht in diesem in den in dem Liederboard bisher, aber man wird's äh sehen, also die KIs, wenn ich das richtig sehe, sind.
Sagen eher weniger voraus während der bisherige Leader Aloha fünf doch 'nen ziemlich hohen Anstieg äh.
Dort prognostiziert, ja.
Wir werden sehen. Gut. Dann ähm wollen wir nochmal einen Blick ins Ausland werfen.
Unbedingt.
Du hast ja nochmal ein paar Länder rausgepickt.
Ähm.
Wer jetzt nicht alles meine erste Wahl gewesen, also wo es ja in der Zeit wirklich nach wie vor schlimm ist, ist ja Tschechien, ne? Also die äh haben die Situation überhaupt nicht im Griff, aber es ist halt nicht das einzige Land
in Europa zumindest, wo es gerade äh Doof läuft.
Ja, ich habe also verschiedene, wie gesagt, verschiedene Länder äh rausgepickt. So ähm.
Griechenland äh kommt jetzt in die zweite Welle so ist jetzt,
sogar in der Institanz deutlich über Deutschland mittlerweile, obwohl es eigentlich ganz gut durchgekommen ist. Das habe ich deswegen als Beispiel gewählt, weil dort ist es halt schon ein bisschen wärmer als bei uns. Sie sind uns wahrscheinlich,
Temperaturmäßig äh wettermäßig, einfach ein, zwei Monate voraus und trotzdem geht's da gerade hoch.
Auch bei den Finnen und Norwegern, die ja.
So bisher, ich sage mal, Musterschüler waren eigentlich eher.
Ja, haben wir, haben wir auch wieder gerade den Anstieg noch nicht ganz drastisch, aber wir hatten ja auch,
einem unserer Klapphauses einen in ähm Norwegen lebenden Exildeutschen.
Ähm der da so ein bisschen berichtete und.
Also die Norweger haben halt auch von Anfang an der Panimie hm auch alle möglichen Maßnahmen ergriffen, wobei.
Keine Lokdowns glaube ich in dem Sinne ähm aber die Leute halten sich wohl alle ganz gut dran, Problem.
Haben sie mit,
Schwedenreisenden, weil dort gerade Alkohol und so halt viel billiger ist, das heißt die haben halt ein Grenzproblem wohl definitiv in Norwegen, dass da halt viel aus Schweden rüber schwappt und.
Rübergeschwappt ist.
Ich das gehört habe. USA natürlich immer von Interesse und.
Die haben's halt geschafft eigentlich jetzt wieder fast äh runterzukommen.
Auf einem Niveau vor der.
Letzten Welle, dass sich das immer so ein bisschen aufgeschaukelt, also mit jeder Welle äh ist es in der USA hochgegangen, aber dann nicht wieder richtig runtergegangen, außer jetzt in der letzten, aber,
auch immer noch auf.
Zumindest den Zahlen nach 'ne deutlich höhere Institution als Deutschland aber dafür testen Sie auch mehr. Also sie sind wahrscheinlich liegen die nicht liegen wir nicht ganz so weit auseinander. Hm,
wie das die reinen äh Zahlen suggeriert.
Ja Schweden hat jetzt auch schon irgendwie ist ist seit Jahresanfang.
In eine dritte Welle gegangen, die aber jetzt auch sie im Griff zu haben scheint, die haben ja da jetzt auch ganz schön politischen Kampf gehabt in Schweden.
Weil äh ja welche Maßnahmen dürfen überhaupt und so, haben neues Gesetz erlassen, um halt mehr eingreifen zu können in das in das tägliche Leben, aber ähm ja.
Gut, dann zu den Ländern, also Estland ging ja jetzt durch die Presse, weil die die Kontrolle verloren haben und die haben jetzt mittlerweile eine fast eine Tausender Institanz.
Erreicht und äh noch keine Zeichen dafür, dass es irgendwie sich abschwächt oder verlangsamt. Also.
Läuft,
gerade krass hoch. Ja und die Tschechens haben gerade jetzt ihre dritte äh Welle äh überschritten, so den den Höhepunkt, wie es aussieht.
Interessant ist, dass sie's jetzt zum dritten Mal geschafft haben, die Institenz auf tausend.
Hochgehen zu lassen so die die Peaks äh sind fast konsistent. Die Tschechien hinlegt. Ähm,
aber das letzte Tal war halt äh ja nur halb so tief wie das Tal davor.
So also es schaukelt sich.
So ein bisschen auf und ja die Situation ich möchte es gar nicht hören die letzten Nachrichten.
Ich da gehört hab waren alle nicht gut, das war mir schlechte Laune. Ja hm.
Interessant ist, sind vielleicht auch nochmal so der der Blick aufs aufs Weltgeschehen.
Also weltweit ziehen die Zahlen auch wieder langsam an.
Was im Wesentlichen aber auf Europa und Südamerika zurückzuführen äh ist.
Andere Regionen konnte ich da jetzt nicht so richtig ausmachen.
China taucht halt gar nicht auf in dem Maßstab, die haben irgendwie äh so ein Pixel am Anfang, so ein Pixel hoch und seitdem ist es, ist dort null.
Afrika.
Tut sich auch nicht viel, wobei man sich bei Afrika halt immer fragt, äh ja, testen die überhaupt, liegt es vielleicht daran, aber.
Es gibt Länder, wo dort auch getestet wird, aber insgesamt ja den reinen Zahlen nach, ist da auch nicht viel los und.
In Indien ebenfalls nicht.
Und Asien ja insgesamt ist dann auch unter ferner Liefen aber eben den Zahlen nach immer noch äh über Indien, Afrika und China sowieso.
Und ja über dem Weltdurchschnitt dann, wenn man jetzt die großen ist halt Russland ähm.
Und dann kommen irgendwann wir und die USA, wir liegen jetzt.
Zumindest, was jetzt die Institzen, die gemeldeten angeht, so.
Gleich äh nehme ich nicht USA, Nordamerika, also also im Prinzip die Kombination aus Kanada und äh den USA liegt jetzt bei deutschem Level. USA liegt noch drüber.
Zählt Nordamerika nur Kanada und USA.
Ich glaube, oder? Ich weiß nicht, was dazu kommt noch, sondern Mexiko ist auch nach Nordamerika, okay, ja, wahrscheinlich, ja klar. Ja. Mhm.
Aber interessanterweise ist das Nordamerika immer eine niedrigere Institz hat als die USA. Na ja und.
So ganz oben, die eben auch von den Großteil des Anstiegs,
verantwortlich sind äh ist halt Südamerika und Europa, das sich halt im neuen Jahr jetzt in Kopf an Kopfrennen liefert, gerade.
Ähm ja.
Und insbesondere die Europäische Union muss man dazu sagen.
Aber interessant ist halt, dass ja, wie gesagt, Europa und Südamerika halt völlig entgegengesetzten Seiten des Globus in entgegengesetzten Jahreszeiten sich befinden.
Also das ist halt auch so ein Indiz dafür, dass äh wenn Saisonalität da ist, äh sie halt nicht äh so gewaltig.
Ist wie bei anderen äh Infektionskrankheiten, was weiß ich wie bei der Grippe, die wirklich von alleine verschwindet oder die die Grippen, die wir haben, die im Sommer dann.
Ja ohne dass wir in Lokdown gehen oder Masken tragen müssen äh dann runtergehen, dass.
Sieht halt bei Kovic nicht so aus.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob die Grippe überhaupt nochmal wiederkommt.
Ja, wir haben ja teilweise, also die arme Grippe, äh die armen Grippe, Viren, die haben halt ja jetzt ziemlichen Kollateralschaden erlebt.
Wenn man sich die Statistiken anguckt, äh im im Surfstadt und so einige von den Gräpeviren sind halt in Deutschland keine Fälle, die detektiert,
jetzt in den letzten Monaten.
Also die Grippe äh sagen wir so, Grippewelle ist ausgeblieben.
Ja selbst selbst die Armen renovieren, ja auch also schnupfen so massiv eingebrochen.
Ich hätt's mir eigentlich so fürs Ende äh der Sendung bereitgelegt, aber Bodo ist schon äh bringst, also äh in Deutschland wird ja auch schon darüber geklagt, dass das äh Geschäft mit Erkältungsmitteln äh einbricht.
So schlimm ist es jetzt eigentlich schon, ne? Also äh und zwar jetzt nicht nur Erkältung, sondern auch so Durchfallläuse.
Das ist alles nicht mehr nachgefragt. Die entsprechende Medikation.
Finde ich überraschend, wenn man mal drüber nachdenkt, ne? Weil das sind halt alles so einerseits virale Sachen, beziehungsweise im Falle von Läuse halt auch eben Kontaktproblematik.
Besondere bei Kitas, insbesondere in Schulen und so, da geht das ja immer rum mit den Läusen, ne? Weil die Kids natürlich die ganze Zeit ihre Köpfe zusammenstecken, nachvollziehbarer Weise und das entfällt natürlich jetzt und dementsprechend haben halt auch die Läuse gerade eine harte Zeit,
und äh Durchfall durch das sind dann die Renovieren, ne? Nee, die Renovieren sind Erkältungs und Novo, die genau die Noroviren, genau, Entschuldigung, die Noroviren
Tja.
Finden auch keine Abnehmer. Also es ist einfach eine schlechte Zeit für Viren generell so außer halt Crowit
der Olle saß zwei, der hat sich ein paar Tricks einfallen lassen, wie man selbst bei den stärksten Beschränkungen noch in irgendeiner Form vorankommt,
aber.
Wir kriegen dich. So viel kann man schon mal sagen. Also da bin ich mittlerweile sicher, ja? Also selbst wenn's nicht weggeht, aber wir werden dieses Problem in den Griff kriegen. Die Frage ist halt nur noch.
Wie viel Convenience Punkte wir so abgezogen bekommen in unserem luxuriösen Lieben.
Muss man ja auch mal sagen, also ich meine, sitzen wir ja irgendwie wohl gemästet vor unseren Bildschirmen und am Internet und Vollversorgung und von Netflix und das volle Programm und Beschwerden uns,
So.
Na ja gut. Ich mein.
Ne, ne, ich meine einen Krankenhausauftakt so mit mit Internet und und und Entertainment, den nimmt man jetzt auch nicht mehr allzu ganz so drastisch wahr, ne? Das war auch mal anders.
Na ja, kommt drauf an. Na, na.
Klar, das war jetzt ein Scherz. Nur um das mal gleich.
Markiert zwar wir falls das nicht gleich rüber kam. Gut, das bringt uns dann ähm zu.
Dem ganzen Themenblockimpfungen. Da müssen wir ja auch mal schauen. Und ähm ja gut, also in Deutschland.
Impfungen finden statt, kann man sagen. Nicht besonders viele, nicht so viele wie wir es gerne hätten,
Aber sie finden statt und es werden auch mehr. Also wir hatten jetzt irgendwie gestern der Donnerstag scheint ja immer so ein bisschen der impffreudigste Tag zu sein. Was ähm.
Ich nur so begrenzt nachvollziehen kann, warum da jetzt Montag, Dienstag immer so schwach sind. Also komischerweise kommen kommen die Impfzentren so am Montag immer schlecht aus dem Wochenende und ich habe mich auch zwischendurch natürlich nochmal gefragt, warum haben wir denn eigentlich diese Einbrüche an den Wochenenden?
Und nach so ein bisschen Twitter-Feedback denke ich, kann man festhalten.
Das ist jetzt nicht, dass da irgendjemand faul rumsitzt, sondern das ist einfach ein Kollateralschaden dessen, dass wir eben insgesamt nicht genug Impfstoffe haben,
Das heißt, viele Impfzentren haben einfach gar nicht genug Material und es würde sich dann auch nicht lohnen.
Termine übers Wochenende zu strecken, weil sie am Ende das auch in fünf Tagen weggeimpft bekommen und sich dann halt.
Sozusagen mit dem Personal, was sie ohnehin schon akkumuliert haben
das aufwächt kommt. Es gibt Impfzentren, die haben auch sieben Tage die Woche offen, das ist in Berlin in der Regel so, teilweise aber mit eingeschränkten Öffnungszeiten, je nach Impfzentrum. Ja und das hängt halt einfach im Wesentlichen
äh davon ab, wenn man auf dieses Impf-Dashboard schaut, sieht man eben auch ganz klar, dass der treibende Faktor hier sind, die Lieferungen der Impfstoffe und man kann auch sagen, alles was so,
geliefert wird, ist dann so nach einer Woche eigentlich auch weg.
Also selbst mit diesem ganzen Vorhalten äh für zweite Impfung et cetera
Das ist also alles, was irgendwie reingekommen ist. Ich kann jetzt hier nochmal genau schauen. Also wir hatten am ersten März ungefähr acht Komma acht Millionen Dosierungen geliefert und äh haben halt jetzt elf Tage,
später äh insgesamt acht Komma sieben Millionen.
Verabreicht. So, also quasi vollständig innerhalb von zwei Wochen geht alles weg.
Und die Impfstofflieferungen steigen an und die Erstimpfung
steigen auch deutlich mit an und wir werden wahrscheinlich jetzt auch demnächst so in zwei in der nächsten Woche vermute ich mal, werden auch die Zweitimpfungen zunehmen
Das wird nicht ganz in dem selben Maße stattfinden, wie die Erstimpfung ansteigen, einfach weil natürlich ein Teil davon Astra Cineca ist und bei Astracinica eben der Abstand bis zur zweiten Impfung jetzt, glaube ich, auf zwölf Wochen hochgesetzt worden ist. Das heißt, da wird dann eben das eine Weile dauern, bis
diese Zahl nachläuft. Insgesamt haben sieben Komma zwei Prozent der Bevölkerung eine erste Impfdosis erhalten,
Ich kann jetzt leider nicht sagen
das vielleicht, äh, wenn du mit deiner anderen Tabelle durch bist, kannst du dir den Datenschutz vielleicht auch nochmal anfangen, da muss man vielleicht mal gucken, vielleicht muss man da jetzt auch jeden Tag wieder irgendwas äh backupen, bevor man äh den Blick zurück nicht mehr hat vom RKI
ja? Nur so als Hinweis ähm auf jeden Fall, was wollte ich jetzt sagen
Geht voran und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass wir so in der nächsten Woche
vielleicht auch schon in dieser Woche so einen Schnitt von zweihunderttausend bis zweihundertfünfzigtausend haben, also eins Komma ähm.
Äh eins Komma fünf Millionen Impfungen pro Woche bis eins Komma sieben, wenn's gut läuft.
Ja, also eigentlich habe ich ja erwartet ähm aufgrund dieser Quartalszusagen, die sehr hoch waren
dass dann wahrscheinlich den Großteil der Lieferung gegen
Ende des Quartals kommen wird, weil dann klingt es immer besser. Ja, ein Quartal eins liefern wir so und zu vier Millionen Dosen und neunzig Prozent kommen dann in der letzten Märzwoche oder so, dann ist das halt immer noch
Ziel erreicht, gut,
Auf der anderen Seite äh schon sagen normalerweise sind ja aufgrund der langen Produktionszeit die Mengen die rauskommen
über Wochen ganz gut vorhersagt, also die letzte Information war, dass so ein Bad jetzt von Biontech
wie fünfzig Tage dauert, vielleicht haben sie es jetzt weiter verkürzt, ursprünglich waren's irgendwie hundert Tage
sie für den Batch, da sind sie auf fünfzig runter verkürzt. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen schneller wird, aber es ist nicht so
dass das irgendwie montags produziert wird und dann dienstags der Impfstoff dann ausgeliefert wird oder so, sondern das dauert halt und deswegen.
Ist es eher unwahrscheinlich, dass man jetzt
positiv überrascht wird, sondern eher geht irgendwas noch schief, was man nicht mit eingerechnet hat oder irgendeine Chemikalie fehlt, das sind ja ganz komplexe auch
Lieferketten, die dahinter stehen und ähm und im Moment ist ja überall weltweit nach allem, was in dem Bereich verwendet wird, so von,
Plastikmaterial und Spritzen und äh Dosen und ähm.
Was was auch immer, aber vor allen Dingen natürlich ja
gewisse Stoffe, die man dann zur RNA-Synthese braucht und und anderes, das kann dann immer mal unvorhergesehen vielleicht ausfallen oder.
Ja, wir hatten ja in unserer Klapphaustalk am Dienstag hatten wir ja auch von äh Besuch von einer Forscherin, die ja dann auch diesen Aspekt aufbrachte, dass sie äh im Labor.
Für ihren eigenen Bedarf schon auf anderes Test äh andere Testmethoden umgehen, also nicht mehr PCR machen, sondern um diesen Lamptest machen und auf unsere Frage mit, ja äh ist in der jetzt so sehr viel toller,
meinte so, ja der ist im letzten Jahr auch immer sehr viel toller geworden und jetzt ist er sogar toller als PCR, was du die Genauigk,
betrifft. Aber der Hauptgrund war einfach, dass man äh da einfach noch das
Material bekommt, da kriegt man die passenden Plastikröhrchen und die entsprechenden Inkredenzchen, die man braucht auf dem Markt wären, alles andere, was halt irgendwie äh PCA,
benötigt natürlich nachgefragt ist ohne Ende uns äh eben auch für den normalen Laborbetrieb dann auch schon an der Stelle auch schon schwierig ist.
Ja. Vielleicht sollte man an der Stelle ja dann doch nochmal auch, weil du es jetzt angesprochen hast, kann ganz äh gut dann doch auch,
mal eine Lanze für einen Lamptest brechen an der Stelle, weil was ich da auch mitgenommen habe ist.
Dass der halt ja vergleichbare oder größere Genauigkeit äh sogar mittlerweile äh hat als der PCR-Test, aber,
du brauchst, um ihn durchzuführen, brauchst du halt keinen Thermocycler, also beim PCR-Test braucht man im Prinzip ein,
elektronisch gesteuerten Ofen, der halt äh seine Temperatur sehr genau äh hebt und absenkt,
und das ist dann immer einer dieser Zyklen, der dann gefahren wird, während
bei den Lemptests man das nur erwärmen muss. Jetzt hätte da irgendjemand hat in der Antarktis äh jetzt damit halt auch getestet äh und
da
genügt dann halt warmes Wasser eigentlich. Äh muss glaube ich auch sechzig Grad erwärmen, äh dass das Ganze für einen Zeitraum von.
Nichts in zehn bis dreißig Minuten, also warmes Wasser, sage ich mal, brauchst du dazu, um den Test durchzuführen oder.
Es gibt halt auch dann alle möglichen elektronischen Geräte, die das dann für dich machen, aber eigentlich braucht man's halt nicht so. Und äh ja, also ich habe mich dann gefragt so, warum da nicht.
Sag mal, der mehr zum Einsatz kommt oder ob das nicht auch dann für bestimmte Einsatzzwecke eine ganz gute Alternative sein könnte. Also.
Neben Schnelltests, äh neben den gewöhnlichen äh äh Latal Flow Schnelltests. Ist halt so ein Lamptest. Einfach mal äh eine ganz andere Kategorie.
An äh Genauigkeit.
Die Genauigkeit ist größer, aber ähm wir haben ja dann auch die Information bekommen. Das Problem ist, er lässt sich halt nicht in dem selben Maße automatisieren, ne, sondern muss halt wieder mehr Präsenz haben und deswegen ist es halt für Massentests
nicht geeignet, aber bevor wir jetzt wieder zu sehr in technische äh Details abdriften, wollte ich mal kurz nochmal
dieser Verfügbarkeit von Impfstoffen und äh Impfkampagnen nochmal was äh sagen. Warum denn das nun eigentlich so ist, ne? Also grundsätzlich haben wir natürlich nicht genug bestellt. Darüber regen sich ja alle auf, aber das Hauptproblem ist, dass das fast
bestellt wurde, nicht geliefert wird. Und
betrifft halt vor allem Astra Cineca und da hat sich ja in den letzten Wochen schon richtiger Krieg äh entwickelt zwischen der EU Kommission und äh Astra Cineca, die ja so ein britisch schwedisches äh Unternehmen äh ist und
Tatsächlich hat bis vor Kurzem, ich weiß jetzt nicht, heute genau tagesgenau, aber Astra Cinica hat.
Einerseits bisher nur zehn Prozent der zugesagten oder weniger als zehn Prozent der zugesagten Menge geliefert.
Schon mal nicht nicht ganz unerheblich, also auf die ganze EU gesehen, ne? Äh und ähm ich hatte ja letztes Mal schon angesprochen, dass dieses Export
äh Verbot dann ausgesprochen wurde
was also wenn Astrazeniker es betrifft im Wesentlichen nur Astracenica. Das heißt, alles was irgendwie in Europa produziert wird und das ist im Wesentlichen in Belgien das äh und Italien, das soll halt irgendwie äh möglichst an die EU auch nicht verlassen, weil einfach Hasra Zinika seine,
liefert zu sagen nicht eingehalten hat und es lässt sich halt auch nicht so ohne Weiteres
steigern und das Racenicke hat jetzt sogar gesagt, dass sie auch die Zusagen in Q zwei
nicht halten werden können. Hundertachtzig Millionen Dosierungen waren bestellt.
Zugesagt und darauf werden's nur siebzig werden, also weniger als die Hälfte. Ähm, das ist alles nicht so gut, ne? Und da kann man noch so viele Impfzentren aufsetzen und noch so viele Leute beschäftigen und die Logistik hochfahren, wenn das Zeug einfach nicht da ist
Dann wird's schwierig, ne? Insbesondere, was halt jetzt auch die Aktivierung von Heimärzten, für die Impfungen betrifft, die alle fordern, aber die halt auch, wo man auch sehen muss,
wenn man das jetzt startet, dann müssen die ja ihren Impfstoff auch irgendwo herbekommen, ne? Und die müssen den über den normalen Medikamentenzuleitung oder über Apotheken
bekommen, also die nutzen dann einfach dieselben Kanäle, die sie jetzt auch für Medikamente benutzen. Und in diese Pipelines muss dann natürlich dann auch entsprechend der Impfstoff,
werden und vorhanden sein und wenn der nicht vorhanden ist, dann ähm na ja, dann kriegen die natürlich ihre Impftermine genauso wenig koordiniert, da sind dann die Impfzentren
mit ihren latent höheren Beständen und der kurzfristigen kurzfristig möglichen Änderungen von Terminlagen und Einbestellungen von äh,
äh temporären Impflingen äh besser aufgestellt.
Ja, also das ist sozusagen das, was diese ganze Debatte jetzt äh macht. Tatsache ist, wenn wir unsere Impfziele erreichen wollen, müssen wir mal locker so das fünf bis sechsfache von dem verimpfen, was jetzt gerade so gemacht wird
und irgendwann im April wird's losgehen mit den Ärzten und vielleicht auch Betriebsärzten. Nur wenn man halt nicht mehr Impfstoff haben, dann,
wird es nix, ne?
Begleitdiskussionen des Ganzen ist natürlich auch die Auflösung der der Impfreihenfolge.
Muss sagen, dass dass beobachte ich so mit meinem ja, mit ein bisschen,
Weißt du, hier, also ich kann die Argumente teilweise nachvollziehen, teilweise nicht. Wir hatten das ja schon mit den Lehrern
ne? Wo man sagen kann, so ja okay, klar, Lehrer sind natürlich betroffen, wenn die Schulen den aufhaben, wo man sich ja fragen kann, so, na ja, aber das Problem ist und die Kinder auch betroffen sind, warum sind sie dann nicht zu?
Plus äh okay, das also es schützt halt die Lehrer, aber es.
Kinder so und da kommen wir ja später nochmal auf beunruhigende Ergebnisse.
Genau. Ähm.
Dann meint Söder jetzt irgendwie, ja, man muss aber auch mal hier irgendwie das starre Impfprotokoll lockern und man will ja jetzt irgendwie auch junge Menschen äh äh impfen lassen,
gut,
das sehe ich nicht so, dann gibt's noch das Argument Hotspots besonders zu bedienen. Also insbesondere hier Tischenreuth und ähm andere Grenzgebiete zu Tschechien.
Da wird halt drüber nachgedacht, ob man dort mehr Impfstoff hinschickt.
Weiß nicht genau, was du davon hältst, aber das ist sozusagen diese Pendlerproblematik an der Stelle, ne.
Ich glaube es gibt noch verdammt viele Leute, die äh eigentlich aus welchen Gründen auch immer äh ganz gerne geimpft werden würden.
Ja klar.
So
Die These ist so ein bisschen, dass man da, wo es halt auch vollkommen außer Rand und Band läuft. Ja, quasi nochmal so einen zusätzlichen äh Brandhemmer mit reinwürft durch die Impfung, was ja dann auch im Sinne aller sein kann, ne.
Es ist es ist halt immer dann sagen bei deiner Impfkampagne es ist immer die Abwägung zwischen einerseits,
ethischen und andererseits anderen,
Aspekten, also wie wie stark priorisierst du den Schutz der Älteren und äh wie stark äh möchtest du die Pandemie eigentlich eindämmen, dass
ist nicht vollständig deckungsgleich, weil ähm ja ähm.
Wenn du halt die Pandimie eindämmen willst, dann impfst du natürlich zuerst die Leute, die potentiell am ehesten als Überträger
in Frage kommen und ansonsten impfst du halt nur komplett die Alten. Wir haben halt eine Kombination auch aus beiden.
Und klar ist das jetzt nicht schwarz und weiß, aber Sonne, Umsteuerung jetzt ja weg von den Alten, also ich finde.
Eigentlich ist die Impfpfote bei den Alten auch leider äh noch viel zu niedrig waren. Also weiß nicht wo der aktuelle Stand.
Ist aber so, als ich das letzte Mal geguckt habe, sind so ungefähr nur vierzig Prozent äh der des Impfstoffes an Alte gegangen, sechzig Prozent äh aufgrund von,
anderen Indikationen verteilt worden und ja,
und in Berlin was jetzt nicht wie wie da jetzt die Quote ist bei den.
Erst geimpften, wie wie viele Leute haben wir jetzt erst geimpft in Berlin, weißt du das zufällig, sonst.
Also nach nach Land kann ich dir das also in Berlin Impfquote, Erstimpfung, meinst du? Äh die liegt bei sieben Komma eins Prozent.
Da sind wir so im Mittelfeld und.
Ja, wie viele, wie viele Leute, wie viele Dosen sind das? Äh sagen, wie viele Leute? Mhm.
In Berlin zweihundertsechzigtausend, die die Erstimpfung erhalten haben.
Ja und wir haben glaube ich etwas über zweihunderttausendachtzig Plus äh in Berlin, wenn ich das.
Richtig sehe, das heißt, die sind
auf jeden Fall die und wenn dann höchstens die Hälfte an die Alten äh gegangen ist, äh sind die mit Sicherheit äh immer noch äh noch dreißig, vierzig Prozent der über achtzigjährigen in Berlin noch ungeimpft.
Obwohl wir jetzt seit zweieinhalb Monaten dabei sind, das ist schon ein bisschen hm.
Es ist ein bisschen hm ja. Aber es hängt halt alles an daran, ne.
Ähm dazu noch eine schöne Webseite
der Kurve neunzehn Impfkampagne, da steckt dahinter das, was steckt da dahinter? Da steckt dahinter das
ZI. Ähm.
Ist ähm Zentralinstitut für die kassenärztliche Versorgung in Deutschland, was es nicht alles gibt.
Ähm und da gibt es ein eine Webseite ein äh Simulator der sozusagen auf Basis der Zusagen der einzelnen Impfhersteller.
Eine Abschätzung macht, wie lange es denn noch dauert insgesamt.
Und ähm na ja das ähm kann auch.
Verrätst du unseren Zuhörern auch, äh was der aktuell so sagt, wie wie lange ist lange.
Ist ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen, also es gibt ja eine eine modellierte Impfquote, die geht dann halt so langsam hoch und die endet auch irgendwann mal hundert Prozent und hundert Prozent ist dann sozusagen äh Ende dieses Jahres. Also wirklich so richtig Weihnachten.
Weihnachten ist alles irgendwie mit Zweitimpfungen komplett durchgeimpft. Ähm,
Jetzt wissen wir erstens, diese hundert Prozent werden wir sowieso nie erreichen
und die hundert Prozent sind auch nicht unbedingt das, was wir erreichen müssen, sondern wir müssen halt irgendwas anderes erreichen und von dem, was es ist, wissen wir noch nicht so ganz genau, was es äh wie hoch es sein sollte.
Ach so und Ende des Jahres werden wir dann hundertsechzig Millionen unverimpfte Dosen übrig haben. Wenn.
Ja klar, weil wir ja eigentlich mehr bestellt haben als wir brauchen.
Geht halt jetzt eben auch einfach davon aus, von den Zusagen, ne? Was dann mit denen geschieht, ist ja nochmal eine andere äh Geschichte, aber wir haben natürlich mehr bestellt als wir brauchen, weil wir ja nicht wussten, woher wir es kriegen.
Und das ist ja insofern auch ganz angemessen, als dass man jetzt sieht, ne? Manche können halt ihre Zusagen nicht einhalten. Ähm ich glaube, das ist eher so ein Randaspekt.
Hinten noch mehr, mehr bestellen sollen.
Ja, hätte, hätte könnte, ne, äh hätte man alles machen müssen, hätte man vielleicht auch äh.
Man muss ja auch Glück haben, ne? Ich meine, es wurde auch bei Sanovi bestellt, aber Sanovi hat halt bis heute keinen Impfstoff äh rausgebracht und ist auch
die gute Frage, ob da jemals noch einer kommen wird. Hätten alle vorher gesagt, so hier Bayerntech, die die machen's, ja. Hätte man natürlich gleich im Februar anrufen können, sagen können.
Hier in einem Monat ist äh Krise schickt uns doch schon mal den Impfstoff.
Ja? Oder man hätte man hätte einfach sagen können, wir nehmen jetzt fünf,
Hersteller und bestellen bei jedem so viel, äh, dass es genug ist. So, wenn so dass wenn nur einer mit dem Impfstoff durchkommt, äh, so äh haben wir wenigstens einen Impfstoff, ja?
Das hätte man wohl tun müssen, aber das war dann auf europäischer Ebene halt auch nicht durchzukriegen. Da haben wir halt einfach so ein bisschen auch das Problem, dass wir eben,
äh das haben wir ja schon ein paar Mal diskutiert, ne
das das was für den Normalbetrieb ein durchaus wünschenswerter Faktor ist, dass es in dieser Politik durch diese Konsensbildung einfach auch eine Verlangsamung äh gibt, die eben dazu führt, dass die Politik auch nicht so leicht durchtreten kann
Ja, uns immer noch wieder ein Regulativ geben kann. Das ist halt einfach für die Krise sehr unpassend
Und deswegen sind wir an der Stelle langsamer als zum Beispiel die Briten, die sich dann in der Hinsicht zumindest noch gefangen haben. Ah, die haben genug andere Sachen falsch gemacht. Von daher habe ich gar keinen Bock auf diesen Vergleich.
Äh nein, das das Ding ist, wir hatten ja auch immer mal wieder die, sozusagen die Kosten und äh die Kosten pro Infektion und.
Da waren wir ja bei, ich sage mal, auf jeden Fall allein schon mal tausend Euro pro Infektion für die entstehenden Krankenhauskosten, weil jeder Zehnte macht dann zehntausend Euro Kosten,
plus dann den entsprechenden Arbeits,
Ausfall. Selbst da kommt man dann äh schon auf äh zwei bis dreitausend Euro nur für die beiden Dinge des langfristigen Gesundheitsschäden und alles andere noch gar nicht eingerechnet. So, das heißt
du hast halt ungefähr pro Million infizierter, drei Milliarden an Kosten und ich glaube das ist so auch die Größenordnung
die eigentlich ursprünglich mal für die gesamt, für die gesamte Impfstoffbeschaffung für die EU äh.
Ursprünglich im äh im Gespräch war, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, Pavel, das Problem ist, dass die dich nicht angerufen haben. Und deswegen läuft's halt anders.
Lass uns zurückkommen zur zur Realität oder zumindest zu simulierten Realität ist ja nicht alles äh verloren. Wenn wir jetzt mal sagen, okay äh die Aussage äh Deutschlands ist.
So ersparen, hat glaube ich irgendwas gesagt von Anfang August, haben alle ein Impfangebot, ne.
Nee. Ähm.
Siebzehnter September oder oder so war glaube ich äh die Ansage, weil äh eine Woche später ist Bundestagswahl.
Ach so. Aha. Das ist ein guter, das ist ein guter Faktor, genau. Bundestagswahl. Also, laut äh Impfsimulator, Bundestagswahl siebenundsiebzig Prozent.
Ja. Ja.
Das ist da kann man, da kann man, da kann man dann schon wieder eine Kneipe aufmachen.
So aus der Abteilung, was eigentlich noch alles so nicht so richtig läuft. Ähm.
Weil diese ganze Zahlenbeschaffung scheint auch schon wieder ein echtes Problem zu sein und diesmal ist es RKI nicht schuld.
Denn äh es gibt da tatsächlich ein digitales äh System, was das RKI gerne hätte, dass die Bundesländer das benutzen,
Das sogenannte digitale Impfquoten-Monitoring, ja,
gibt's bestimmt auch schönere Worte, die man hätte nehmen können, aber so ist das nun mal, ne? Ähm.
Auf jeden Fall das Problem damit ist benutzen nicht alle
sondern nur fünf von sechzehn Bundesländern nutzen dieses DIM, um die Zahlen ans RKI zu melden
Das sind Baden-Württemberg, Bremen, Hamburg, Niedersachsen und das Saarland
Äh in Bayern benutzt keine einzige äh Stelle, kein einziges Impfzentrum das System. Also in anderen Ländern ist es wohl teils so, teils so. Ja, also noch nicht mal einheitlich kaputt, sondern auch noch uneinheitlich kaputt
Stattdessen werden die Zahlen per E-Mail äh geschickt
und da sind dann Excel Tabellen dran oder auch mal andere Formate und beim RKI sitzt irgend so ein bemitleidenswürdige Person
diese ganzen Daten immer empfängt und dann immer rumkonvertieren muss und mit Copy und Pace in irgendein anderes System wieder überführen muss. Sie meinen, das würde ihnen so vier Stunden mehr Arbeit täglich äh kosten. Allein um die Impfzahlen.
Zu notieren. Grund.
Die Länder hätten ja gerne auch teilweise eine Einbindung in ländereigene Systeme.
Und sehnsicher dann halt nicht in der Lage, dass diese lindereigenen Systeme wiederum dieses digitale Impfquotenmonitoring benutzen kann.
Ist verständlich, weil das teilweise eben auch an diesem ganzen Terminmanagement mit dranhängt, aber ich bitte, also wirklich,
wir reden hier wirklich von der über der Tabulierung von wie viel Leute habt ihr geimpft? Also es ist einfach
nichts was nicht irgendwie so ein Everage-Startup Guide irgendwie in der Woche mal runterprogrammieren
da so eine API irgendwie zu befüllen, die Daten von irgendwo mit dem SQL rauszulesen und die dann einfach auf Knopfdruck oder einfach automatisch zu versenden. Ich verstehe nicht, warum das immer alles so ein
so totales Hexenwerk sein muss wo es einfach nur darum geht ein paar Bikes durch das Internet zu verschicken,
es ist einfach furchtbar, ne? Ja.
IT-Entwicklung im Gesundheitswesen ja äh schon Front von mir äh arbeitet äh.
Bereich und,
dauert normalerweise so eine Systemspezifikation zwei Jahre bevor da überhaupt jemand anfängt Hand anzulegen sind die ersten zwei Jahre rum bevor irgendwie alle sich überhaupt einig darüber sind wie denn
die Spezifikation auszulegen ist und wie sie denn mit dem ganzen Datenschutzverfahren und das ist halt in dem Bereich.
Schon ich meine auf der einen Seite erfreulich so also,
Ich kann mich jetzt nicht dran erinnern, dass bei uns jetzt wo
größere Mengen an Daten jemals also an Gesundheitsdaten aus irgendwelchen Kassen oder so abhanden gekommen wären, wo man.
Also sich aus anderen Ländern, dass alle naselang hört, dass da so mal eben ähm Daten von dreißig Millionen Patienten oder so mal im Internet standen des äh wird's
ist in Deutschland eher sehr unwahrscheinlich dafür, sind wir halt sehr extrem äh dann,
ja an der anderen Ecke und äh das fällt uns halt jetzt ein bisschen auf die Füße. Äh.
Ich wollte nur nochmal klarstellen, es gibt tatsächlich die Impfverordnung und die schreibt diese Meldung vor.
Ja, aber die Länder sind halt für die Umsetzung verantwortlich und haben's halt einfach nicht umgesetzt. Ja.
Auf Anfrage konnte das BMG noch nicht mal die Zahl der Impfstellen nennen, die es äh gibt. Das wohl auch was,
auch damit zu tun hat, dass es wohl eine variable Zahl von mobilen Impfteams gibt und so weiter, ne. Trotzdem, man will ja es ist immer so, du denkst immer.
Krise und Government und dann denkst du, du stellst dir so ein Warroome vor mit so großen Bildschirmen, wo dann irgendwie die ganzen Daten reinlaufen und du hast so den Fullover View
Statistik stattdessen sitzen sie da mit einem Monokel und schauen irgendwie auf gefaxte Excel-Tabellen.
Mhm.
So sieht's nämlich aus.
So, kommen wir jetzt mal zur Wissenschaft.
Ähm bei den Impfstoffen wollen wir nicht, ich meine äh noch irgendwas jetzt zu dem Impfstoff in Dänemark und Norwegen sagen. Astra Senika.
Genau, das hatte ich jetzt gerade vor.
Ähm genau, weil abgesehen von den Lieferproblematiken gibt's natürlich weiterhin viel Diskussion um Astra Sinneka, wie du schon gesagt hast. Es gibt jetzt gerade einen Impfstopp in Dänemark und in Norwegen.
Weil so Thrombosefälle irgendwie aufgetreten sind. Ich kann das nicht beurteilen, nur.
Karl Latterbach sagt
die Zahlen, die da äh angegeben werden, sind völlig normal. Also würde man sozusagen die Leute nicht geimpft haben und man würde sich anschauen, wie viel Thrombose dort auftritt, dann wäre das sozusagen genau das Gleiche. Kann ich nicht beurteilen, habe die Zahlen, ich kenne die nicht, aber das war die Aussage, die ich so mit
kommen habe, auch die WHO sagt, mach mal weiter so oder so ist natürlich jetzt der Schaden wieder da, weil natürlich das Geschrei groß ist, sogar irgendwie äh
im Radio äh klapperte es so durch und meine Tochter kam ganz aufgeregt zu mir und meinte so, oh man kann jetzt sterben von von der Impfung,
So
so, weil's irgendwie einen Todesfall gegeben hat, halt mit Thrombose, plus ob das eben mit dieser Impfung zusammenhängt, ist vollkommen unklar und eben rein von den Zahlen her vollkommen äh nicht,
belegbar und dann halt genauso gut einfach sein, dass es eben einfach so passiert ist, ne. Weil sowas einfach passiert. Ja
Dabei ist der Impfstoff so toll. Also es gibt neue ähm Studien, die also astra Sinnika mit ähm zwei Impfungen, mit zwölf Wochen Abstand sehr, sehr, sehr gute
Zahlen belegen, also hier so eine Studie bei The Lanced,
nochmal festgestellt, achtzig Prozent nach erster Dosis, das durchaus was.
Man sagen kann über diesen Impfstoff und laut den Zahlen.
Werden auch symptomatische Infektionen zwar nicht vollständig verhindert, ja? Sieht aber eben so aus, als ob die auch nicht mehr ansteckend sind.
Also diese Impfstoffe tun genau das, was wir wollen. Sie verhindern zu hundert Prozent,
dass man stirbt, sie verhindern zu hundert Prozent, dass man überhaupt einen schweren Verlauf hat, sie verhindern mit einer sehr, sehr, sehr hohen Rate, dass man überhaupt,
irgendwelche symptomatischen Verläufe hat, selbst wenn die milde sind und mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es einfach die Informationslage, die sich in zunehmendem Maße verdichtet. Ist halt auch die Infektion,
gesenkt,
stark gesenkt, signifikant gesenkt, vielleicht nicht zu hundert Prozent gesenkt, aber so oder so sieht es danach aus, dass selbst wenn man geimpft ist und sich nochmal infiziert. A darunter nicht leidet,
B
Dass wenn man überhaupt noch in der Lage ist damit andere Leute anzustecken, dass die Dosis so gering ist, dass eben auch deren Verläufe äh auch dann äh nicht stark sein können, selbst wenn sie.
Selber nicht geimpft sind. Ja, das kann man nochmal so zu Astra Sinica äh festhalten.
Ja vielleicht auch nochmal, weil ich gelegentlich auch äh sagen mal gucke und höre, was tut sich denn so in.
Impfskeptiker kreisen und was sind dort die Argumente oder Argumentationen und da kommt der,
Vorwurf gerade äh so ja bei diese ganzen ähm also hier in dem Fall ähm,
diese ganzen Zerokovit äh Spinner und äh Impf äh wütigen äh so für die äh ist ja dann jeder, der irgendwie,
ähm Kovet
hatte ist dann wegen Kovic äh krank und stirbt wegen Kovic, aber bei den Impfstoffen äh auf einmal angeblich, wenn da was passiert, dann war es nicht der Impfstoff, sondern dann war's irgendwas anderes,
das ist sozusagen dort äh die Argumentation, mit der sie äh um die Ecke kommen und dem kann man.
Eigentlich dann nur durch vernünftige Zahlen äh halt auch begegnen, was Kovit anrichtet.
Wissen wir, da kennen wir die Zahlen äh mittlerweile und,
bei den Impfungen, zumindest wissen wir äh bei der großen Anzahl in einigen Ländern, also England, aber auch USA und äh Israel äh da ist,
halt sind diese Impfstoffe millionenfach verabreicht worden, viel millionenfach und.
Ich hab jetzt noch nicht von statistisch auffälligen Häufungen von irgendwas nach Impfung gehört, also aus Hates natürlich bestimmte.
Symptome, die sich die sich entwickelt haben, aber zumindest sagen nichts wo nach längerer Zeit, also wo das ist gehäuft zu Todesfällen äh äh käme, aber klar.
Keine Symptome, sondern Impfwirkung, also das ist ja sozusagen Wirkungs äh Folgen, ne? Also die Impfung als solche soll ja auch eine Wirkung haben.
Die Wirkung ist fahr dein Immunsystem hoch und das hat dann eben entsprechende Auswirkungen wie Fieber et cetera. Das ist das, was beobachtet.
Genau, aber idealer, also gut, die hatten wir, das hatten wir ja neulich auch auf auf Klapphaus, äh diese diese Debatte und da fand ich
schon den Einwand einer höheren oder einer Teilnehmerin dort
ganz ganz richtig sie sagt OK die beabsichtigte Wirkung ist die Immunisierung und insofern sind alle anderen Dinge die jetzt eventuell,
wegen der Immunisierung,
passieren die müssen aber nicht passieren so es gibt halt auch ganz viele Leute die merken da nicht wirklich viel. Ich
weiß es nicht, ob das auch so eine Altersgeschichte ist. Also ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern, jemals nach einer Impfung irgendwie.
Mich anders gefühlt zu haben so, aber äh das liegt jetzt auch schon eine ganze Weile zurück. Äh ich werde.
Demnächst einmal meine Impftour äh antreten, äh habe ich mir überlegt, aber so ja, ich weiß nicht, wie es, wie war's bei dir, kannst du dich an irgendwie,
Impfung erinnern, wo es dir danach schlecht ging.
Ne, also ich ich also ich kenne Leute in meinem Umfeld, hatten das, ja, Grippeimpfung und dann wirklich mal so einen Tag
so bisschen Fieber, bisschen niedergeschlagen und nochmal ein paar Stunden äh geschlafen und so weiter. Vielleicht bin ich ein bisschen müder gewesen, da kann ich mich jetzt nicht so richtig dran erinnern, aber nie, dass es mich jetzt so richtig weggehauen hätte.
Neben einem Punkt war, also ich will jetzt nie in Frage stellen, dass es das gibt, die Impfreaktionen wahrscheinlich, wenn man darauf achtet, äh so sich alle fünf Minuten fragt, wie fühle ich mich, dann fallen die bestimmt noch.
Intensiver aus, aber zu sagen, ich fand einfach nur den Gedanken, sagen, was sind denn meine persönlichen Erfahrungen mit Impfung gewesen und da,
vielleicht mal jeder einfach auch sich selber mal fragen, ob er sich denn überhaupt erinnern kann jemals Probleme gehabt zu haben nach Impfungen oder,
sagt, dass es dann vielleicht auch ein Indiz dafür äh vielleicht gibt's einfach Leute, die Impfungen besser oder schlechter vertragen.
Definitiv. So, das ist halt einfach so, da kann man aber auch wenig wenig gegen machen, aber selbst wenn wenn man halt äh Auswirkungen hat, die gehen weg, die sind nicht tödlich,
Die sind nicht problematisch. Es gibt sehr, sehr wenige Fälle, wo Leute halt
somit aller allergischen Reaktionen kam, das muss behandelt werden, das kann aber auch behandelt werden
Überall, wo man sich impfen lässt, ist man auch mal fünfzehn Minuten
vor Ort und das passiert dann auch innerhalb dieser fünfzehn Minuten, wenn da nichts mehr passiert, dann ist es halt eher so etwas, was sich dann so schleichend über ein paar Tage noch entwickelt, aber es ist halt einfach an sich kein großes Problem. Ich meine, es war eh schon damit zu rechnen, aber es ist halt einfach jetzt so,
Millionenfach werden Leute gerade geimpft. Was sagen die Zahlen? Wie viele äh Dinger gehen jetzt pro Tag äh weg.
Also nach den aktuellen Weltzahlen.
Haben wir eine Impfquote von ungefähr so zwischen sieben und acht Millionen pro Tag.
Da befinden wir uns jetzt gerade.
Jeden Tag sieben Millionen, wenn's da nennenswerte grundsätzliche Probleme gäbe, würde diese Impfkampage überhaupt nicht stattfinden.
Dann hätten wir auf jeden Fall schon was davon gehört. Ne? Ja okay, gut.
Gehen wir mal weiter zu äh neuen Impfstoffen
die gibt's ja auch und zwar wird das Portfolio in äh bald in absehbarer Zeit hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt, bald äh erweitert und zwar gibt's einen weiteren auch in Europa mittlerweile zugelassenen Impfstoff, also genau genommen ist er noch nicht,
zugelassen oder weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das schon passiert ist. Tatsache ist, die EMA empfiehlt die Zulassung, das muss ja dann rechtlich die Kommission tun, die sie aber dann eben nichts anderes macht, als ihren Friedrich-Wilhelm da auch runterzusetzen
Und ja, der Johnson in Johnson äh Impfstoffe zugelassen. Ein weiterer äh Vektorimpfstoff aus den USA.
Und das Besondere daran ist, dass es sich um den ersten Impfstoff handelt, der auch nur eine einzige Impfdosis braucht,
Mir ist nicht so ganz klar, was da jetzt im Design anders ist oder ob die einfach nur gesagt haben, wir sind uns sicher, dass er hier äh mit einer Impfdosis hinkommt. Wir testen das gar nicht anders und wir gehen dann immer in diese Phase drei Trials und testen das.
Das haben sie dann auch gemacht, auch wieder mit extrem vielen Teilnehmern, also in diesem Fall vierundvierzigtausend Teilnehmer und auch hier gab's
Sechsundsechzig Prozent Effizienz gegen mittelschwere und schwere Verläufe, also nochmal zur Erinnerung, diese Effizienz. Man muss ja mal sagen, Effizienz gegen was, ne?
Bedeutet, dass halt bei zwei Drittel der Teilnehmer überhaupt nichts aufgetreten ist und bei ein Drittel
ist irgendwie was aufgetreten, aber auch hier gab's wieder keinen Todesfall
und die Hospitalisierung äh ist sogar um fünfundachtzig Prozent runtergegangen, also nur fünfzehn Prozent hatten ähm nach einer Woche.
Überhaupt noch den Bedarf ins Krankenhaus zu gehen. Äh nach achtundzwanzig Tagen, also vier Wochen nach der Impfung hundert Prozent
Einschränkung der Hospitalisierung. Also mit anderen Worten einen Monat, nachdem man diesen Impfstoff bekam, hat niemand, der geimpft wurde, musste noch ins Krankenhaus wegen irgendwas,
Also wegen Covit.
Also es ist dann, ich sag mal deutlich mehr und schnellere Wirksamkeit als jetzt sowohl bei Astra Sinnica als auch bei Biontech.
Die äh gut muss jetzt sehen, ob das auch in der Praxis in vergleichbaren.
Situation dann so ist aber ja.
In England waren's ja bei den beiden sagen fünf Wochen nach der ersten Dosis, waren's so ähm.
Um die neunzig Prozent, also einer hatte glaube ich so vierundneunzig, der andere einundneunzig oder so Prozent ähm.
Vitalisierung, ne?
Horst bei der äh also Verhinderte Hospitalisierungen, das heißt.
Wenn der wirklich zu hundert Prozent nach achtundzwanzig Tagen die Hospitalisierung vermeidet, ist das natürlich dann auch ein idealer Impfstoff, um damit äh gerade.
Gefährdeten äh zu.
Weil das geht dann natürlich ganz schnell. Also ja äh klingt klingt doch gut.
Genau, klingt gut. Ähm gibt noch ein paar andere positive Aspekte und noch einen Nachteil. Also zunächst einmal der ist ab achtzehn Jahren erstmal zugelassen, also auch hier ist mit jüngeren Leuten noch nicht ausreichend getestet worden. Das wird dann sicherlich noch,
kommt und ähm ja, was bedeutet denn das? Also der ist drei Monate lagerfähig bei normaler
Kühlung, also das ist ja so typisch Vektor äh Impfstoff, also in dem Moment, wo man halt diese RNA,
Oder äh dieser, also in dem Moment, wo man die Bauanleitung für den ähm für dieses Bike-Protein in einen Virushülle packt.
Ist.
DNA effektiv, ja.
Und auch noch als DNA ist das einfach beständiger. Deswegen müssen die nicht so lange äh nicht so heftig gekühlt werden. Das ist einfach der generelle Vorteil von allen Impfstoffen, die halt ähm
quasi auf einer viralen Hülle basieren, also sowohl die Vektorimpfstoffe als eben dann auch so die Tod und lebt lebendig Impfstoffe und ähm
außerdem.
Bringt natürlich die Tatsache, dass das hier nur eine Dosis erforderlich ist, macht diesen Impfstoff noch für was ganz anderes, nämlich äh interessant, was man mal bedenken muss, denn bei so einer Impfkampagne.
Mit einer Zweitimpfung. Ist ja sozusagen diese zweite Impfung auch nochmal so ein logistisches Detail, das muss gemeistert werden.
Die Person muss dann halt auch am Start sein. Und deswegen eignet sich halt der Johnson und Johnson im Stoff. Äh vor allem für Leute.
Die äh so ein bisschen so Problemfälle sind, sagen wir mal Leute wie Obdachlose oder ähm.
Jemand, der im Gefängnis geimpft wird, aber dann irgendwie ein paar Wochen später entlassen wird. Weißt du, wo du, wo du dann einfach diese diese
Rolle nicht mehr ohne weiteres ausüben kannst, so. Ähm
Und du kannst auch generell Massenimpfungen einfach besser organisieren, weil du dann eben nicht so viel Buch führen musst über die zweite Impfung und wir brauchen hier eine ladbare Anschrift und so weiter, sondern die werden einfach geimpft, kriegen ihren Zettel und fertig
Ne? Also das ist definitiv so ein Aspekt.
Der hier jetzt noch mit dazu kommt und das ist schon äh bisher erstaunlich gewesen, was wir so für so einen Impfstoffarsenal haben, aber durch den John Sohn Johnson Impfstoff ähm wird es noch besser. Jetzt kommt äh der Kaviar.
Das Problem ist, dass wir den wahrscheinlich kaum sehen werden bis Ende Juni.
Es gibt die Zusage äh der EU fünfundfünfzig Millionen Dosen zu liefern, aber halt bis Anfang Juli und man geht davon aus, dass das eben auch alles erst sehr spät stattfinden kann
Und das hat damit zu tun, dass er vor allem in USA produziert wird und es in USA derzeit einfach so ein Auslieferverbot gibt. Das heißt, alles, was in USA produziert wird,
darf die USA nicht verlassen, obwohl die jetzt schon totalen Überbestand an Impfstoffen haben.
Und erst wenn die USA, sagen wir mal, an so einem Punkt angekommen ist, dass sie sagen, so okay, alles klar, jetzt haben wir auch genug und mehr brauchen wir auch nicht mehr, jetzt dürfen die anderen auch mal ran,
Also da ist auch äh Europa quasi so ein Zweitweltland, äh was so,
Impfstoffe betrifft und dann sehen wir mal, wie es äh anderen immer geht, wenn man so in der Hackordnung, der internationalen Gemeinschaft ein bisschen unter irgendjemandem steht,
Das kennen wir ja nicht so sehr, ne? Und genau diese Situation haben wir jetzt und leiden ein bisschen drunter.
Also Grund zur Hoffnung, aber mit äh mit Asterisk.
Dann nochmal was zu den zu der Forschung in United Kingdom,
gibt es jetzt so Cowit Human Challenges und das ist irgendwie sehr äh umstritten. Gibt da so ein Projekt, das gibt's schon eine Weile.
Als One Day, Suna dort org und der Name liegt schon so ein bisschen nahe, worum's hier geht. Hier geht's dadrum, irgendwie äh kostet was es wolle, dafür zu sorgen, dass wir irgendwie früher aus dieser ganzen.
Krise rauskommen und da gibt's dann irgendwie so einen Freiwilligenprojekt von Leuten, die suchen nach achtzehn bis dreißig Jahre alten, gesunden Leuten, die ungeimpft sind und sich gezielt infizieren lassen mit Covit.
Man nennt das eine Human Challenge und sowas gab's auch schon mal für Grippe und Malaria früher.
Aber das bedeutet natürlich,
Du infizierst diese Leute und bringst dir natürlich potenziell extrem in Gefahr, ne? Äh was da gemacht werden soll, ist halt ähm Sachen zu erforschen, die man eben so in der Breite mit diesen ganzen Zufall, Placebo vergleichen,
nur mit sehr großem Aufwand und mit sehr langen Zeitraum machen kann, ne? Also so Fragen wie
Was ist denn eigentlich die minimale Dosis, die man braucht, um jemand zu infizieren.
Ja? Da gibt's tausend Untersuchungen und Schätzungen und statistische Modelle und äh Beobachtungen und hier noch eine Studie, die sagt das und dann auch eine Studie, die dir sagt,
das und dann gibt's dreißig Studien und dann gibt's eine Meterstudie, die das alles irgendwie nochmal vergleicht und dann gibt's nochmal eine Meter-Meter-Studie und irgendwann meint man vielleicht, man wäre irgendwo, aber was die halt versuchen, herauszufinden ist, okay, wie ist es denn jetzt hier konkret?
Wir infizieren jetzt einfach mal Leute mit der und der Dosis oder versuchen sie zu infizieren mit der und der Dosis und schauen dann halt, hat es geklappt oder hat's nicht geklappt.
Und natürlich dann auch äh was braucht's denn sozusagen, ne? Also,
Wie kann man die denn infizieren? Ariosohe, Luftfilter, äh et cetera. All diese ganzen Fragen und du benutzt dann halt die Menschen im Prinzip wie Mäuse, wie Labormäuse und ja,
Fragt man sich so, okay.
Muss das sein? Ethisch, ne? Schwierig und ähm das ist wohl auch so, dass man das irgendwie so in Deutschland, wo so niemals machen würde, so wie die Wissenschaft hier aufgestellt ist, aber in äh Großbritannien gibt's das,
und ich habe mal so ein bisschen geschaut, was die Leute so für eine Motivation haben und irgendwie ist es auch so ein bisschen.
Erinnerung an meine Jugend muss ich sagen, ne? Da kommen dann so Aussagen wie na ja, hier der ganze Lokdown, das ist ja alles ganz furchtbar äh.
Würde hier lieber hier irgendwie das noch zehn Mal irgendwie machen, hier irgendwie mich zu infizieren, das ist so eine Aussage von jemand, der sich mal infiziert hat,
als Jugendlicher, also nicht groß betroffen war, äh als noch länger diesen Lokdaum äh zu machen. Das war jetzt eine natürlich eine Aussage von der Person, die.
Da in der Organisation mitarbeitet, aber selber natürlich da sie schon mal infiziert war,
nicht machen kann, aber andere sagen halt so, ja, nee, ich mache da einfach mit, weil äh wie ich will der Gemeinschaft was Gutes tun und mir kann ja nichts passieren und so.
Nachvollziehbar, wenn man so jung ist, dann denkt man ja sowieso, man so sterben tun ja, tun ja immer nur die anderen, ne? Also es ist ja irgendwie so, man man kann sich ja irgendwie gar nicht
vorstellen, wenn man so vierzehn ist, das sind ja so Leute, die vierunddreißig sind, sind ja uralt, ne? Und,
sechzig kann man sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen, dass man dann in den nächsten äh zweihundert Jahren irgendwie dieses Alter erreichen könnte, aber das ist dann halt etwas, was sich dann irgendwann mal äh ändert und wenn man dann mal so ein Alter erreicht hat, wo dann irgendeine Gebrechlichkeit
das erste Mal wirklich einsetzt, ja, dass man mal irgendwie nicht drei Tage die Nächte durchmachen kann oder irgendwie der Rückenschmerz oder
Knie weh tut oder sonst irgendwie sich was mal ein paar Tage chronisch hält
dann fängt man halt an, diese diese eigentliche Gebrechlichkeit auch anders zu sehen und ich schätze mal, dass so ein Projekt schon genug Freiwillige finden wird.
Das ist so mein Eindruck.
Also ich,
bin da so ein bisschen gespalten, wenn ich das höre, letztlich ist das aber auch eine philosophische Frage, wie viel äh Verantwortung äh gibt man dem Einzelnen, ich meine, das sind alles Freiwillige,
zu versagen gut, wenn die Leute halt wollen
Also solange es da jetzt irgendwie kein keinen Druck äh gibt oder andere Dinge, die man klar
Problem könnte natürlich sein, dass das auch Leute anzieht, die sich irgendwie endlich immunisieren wollen auf der anderen Seite gibt's dafür in England jetzt einfachere Möglichkeiten wahrscheinlich, man muss jetzt nicht mehr sich äh den
Virus holen, wobei, wir sehen also noch ist auch hier bei uns der Virus noch führend, was so das Immunisieren angeht.
Wobei was ich mich frage, hm es äh äh halt ähm wie.
Da habe ich jetzt seit längerem nichts mehr äh darüber gehört, wie gut die Immunisierung durch,
die Krankheit im Vergleich äh zur Immunisierung jetzt durch den Impfstoff eigentlich ist, so mal unabhängig davon, was du halt vorher so durchmachst und.
Ähm so meine Vermutungen noch einmal, die ich weiß, ist, dass es äh sagen wir schon
einen Teil der Leute deutlich besser immunisieren könnte, wenn das überhaupt noch möglich ist als als äh die Impfstoffe, aber bei einem Teil
Leute eben auch kein selbst durch die Krankheit ähm jetzt nicht unbedingt eine langanhaltende Immunität entsteht. Auf der anderen Seite.
Sollte es theoretisch anders sein, ne? Ich sollte sagen, die äh Krankheit,
selbst äh sagen bei gesunden Leuten für die beste Immunität äh äh sorgen. Nicht, dass es jetzt empfehlen würde, da kommen wir, glaube ich, gleich noch auf dieses wirklich interessante Bild äh,
Ähm das habe ich halt die ganze Zeit schon während der Sendung im im Hinterkopf so immer, wenn mir sagen von Infektionen äh reden, weil ähm ja,
Das äh ist nämlich auch dann kommen wir vielleicht jetzt zu dem Thema, weil wir sind jetzt schon ganz schön lange äh äh dabei.
Ich kann, ich kann dir auf deine Frage auf jeden Fall noch kurz was äh beantworten. Ähm jetzt geht
gerade die Webseite nicht, aber äh ich habe da tatsächlich gestern äh vorgestern einen Pepa besprochen, gehört und ähm.
Da kam genau dieser Aspekt zur Sprache. Leider habe ich jetzt die Grafik nicht direkt vor mir, aber man hat halt mal untersucht, wie ist denn so der Aufbau von Antikörpern bei den Leuten und ähm
Ne? Also wie wie gut ist die Immunisierung? Das war ja im Prinzip deine Frage, ne? Und äh da wurde dann zwischen Milden und schweren Verläufen unterschieden und die Spannbreite der Antikörperbildung, also der der tatsächlichen
Aufbau der der Immunantwort hat sich sowohl,
milden Infektionsbereich, also auch im schweren Infektionsbereich extrem gestreckt. Also der, das war sehr breit gestreut oder mal anders gesagt. Wenn man Corona hat, wenn man Kowith erkrankt.
Dann ist die Bandbreite deiner Immunreaktion so von fast gar nicht bis ziemlich viel. Und bei schweren Verläufen ist sie von auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen.
Bis extrem stark. Und das heißt man kann das gar nicht jetzt,
vom Verlauf abhängig machen, sondern es hängt auch sehr von der Person ab und es ist ein bisschen Zufall. Oder anders ausgedrückt. Es gibt eine relativ.
Hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass deine Immunisierung nicht besonders gut ist. Und.
Bei Impfstoffen weiß man, aber wiederum, dass die Immunisierung sehr gut ist.
Und deswegen ist eigentlich die Schlussfolgerung alle Leute, die auch schon Corona hatten, sollten sich definitiv äh impfen lassen.
Weil man weiß es nicht und was ich mir gut vorstellen kann ist ähm wir hatten das ja so ein paar Sendungen auch wie,
die Immunanfahrt äh eigentlich aussieht und als erstes kommt ja das angeborene Immunsystem daher und wenn entweder die in.
Der Virus zu schwach oder,
nicht davon abgekriegt hast oder wenn du halt äh einen einfach hammergutes angeborenes
Immunsystem hast, äh dass halt diesen Virus einfach so schnell wegfegt
ohne dass es ähm irgendwie jetzt speziell erstmal Antikörper für den Virus bauen muss, sondern das wird halt quasi im Rahmen der normalen
Putzaktion, also ich sag mal der normalen Standardpolizeipatrouille
die ist halt so gut ausgebildet und so.
Gut, dass die halt, ja, diesen Virus äh einfach wegräumt, ohne dass du halt jetzt über das äh,
erworbene Immunsystem dann quasi dir so eine ständige Anti-Corona-Einsatztruppe oder zumindest ein Anti-Corona Einsatzplan entwickeln musst mit Reservisten
für den Fall, dass Korona wiederkommt und wieder deine normalen Polizeitruppen
umgangen werden äh äh das dann aber halt die sozusagen die Experten im Immunsystem dessen aha Corona und.
Gegen Korona helfen halt die und die Antikörper und die äh da schmeißen jetzt die Anti-Corona Antikörperfabriken äh,
an und äh ja manche Leute brauchen das aber gar nicht. Diesen,
sozusagen da räumt, dass halt die normale Polizei weg, was aber nicht heißt, dass es immer so bleibt oder dass wenn sie mit einer heftigen Dosis erwischt werden äh sie damit immer noch klarkommen
oder was weiß man halt nicht. Deshalb ja trotz alledem äh denke ich fährt man mit der Impfung am besten.
Aber zumindest in der Theorie äh nach allem, was ich gehört habe, äh vielleicht nicht gerade bei Corona, aber oft bei anderen äh äh Viren ist es so, dass,
sagen das lebende Ding.
Schon äh oft ja, wobei natürlich der lebende Virus dann auch also viele Viren dann wiederum Mechanismen haben, die das Immunsystem umgehen,
das will man natürlich auch nicht haben und deswegen ja.
Denke hm impfen so.
Auf jeden Fall impfen. Genau und es gibt noch einen weiteren äh neuen Aspekt, der fürs Impfen äh spricht und zwar ist das eine ganz interessante Untersuchung
in Bezug auf die Wirkung von Impfstoffen, auf Long-Kovit,
Also Longkovet, wir haben ja den Begriff schon etabliert, ist die Bezeichnung für wenn die Krankheit lange Ärger macht, ne? Bei vielen Leuten geht es ja vorbei, aber es gibt auch eben einen bestimmten Prozentsatz
von Leuten, die leiden dann eben unter Longkowit und man hat sich natürlich gefragt, warum eigentlich.
Also ein Viertel hat fünf Wochen später noch mindestens ein Symptom. Nass ist lang, fünf Wochen für eine Grippe oder.
Genau und es gibt Leute, bei denen ist es monatelang, ne? Also,
gibt, also abgesehen jetzt von, wo so unmittelbaren Schäden, wie vernarbtes Lungengewebe und so weiter, was ja potenziell dann auch ein Leben lang äh bleibt, also.
Also je nachdem wie sehr der Körper in der Lage ist, das sagen wir mal durch den Zellaustausch über die Zeit irgendwie noch zu verbessern, aber das.
Wird sich wahrscheinlich nie wieder auf hundert Prozent hochfahren äh können.
Gibt's aber einfach diese permanente Unruhe, dieser permanente Unruhezustand so. Und es gibt so drei verschiedene Thesen im Wesentlichen, was da sozusagen passiert. Ich bin mir nicht hier hundertprozentig sicher, ob ich das jetzt so akkurat wiedergeben kann
aber so. Das eine ist halt, dass im Körper sich irgendwo so ein persistenter wie so ein Virusreservoir hält, was irgendwie nicht so richtig bekämpft wird,
Ja? Was aber immer wieder so eine Unruhe auslöst, also was immer wieder so sich wegverteilt oder aber nie so richtig weggekämpft wird,
Ja, das heißt, das Immunsystem ist nicht so richtig in der Lage, da das, dass du diese diese äh wie sagt man so schön immer bei.
Muss diese Widerstandszellen so komplett ne, so ein gallisches Dorf sozusagen, ja? Wo wo du einfach nicht gegen ankommst, so, weil weil weil die haben irgendwie Zaubertrank und du nicht, ne.
Dann gibt's äh das Konzept eines sogenannten Virol Ghost, also also eines Virusgeists. Das sind so äh nur Fragmente des Virus.
Also Proteine, RNA, das heißt das Virus selber ist vielleicht gar nicht mehr da,
Aber quasi so als Überbleibsel dieser ganzen Kämpfe hast du so eine Vatamorgana in Form so einzelner Teile auf die
das Immunsystem immer wieder reagiert. Das heißt, du leidest in dem Moment gar nicht so sehr durch die Virusaktivität, sondern du leidest dadurch, dass dein Immunsystem immer wieder auf irgendwas reagiert, obwohl eigentlich schon alles bekämpft ist.
Dass da noch zu viel Müll unterwegs ist.
Genau, dass da so Müll rumliegt und dass das nervt dich einfach und reg dich auf und äh du bist immer der Meinung, du müsstest da irgendjemand hinschicken und der kommt da wieder und sagt, da ist doch gar nichts. So, nein, ich weiß ganz genau, dass das, was ist, ich höre stimmen.
Ähm und dritte These, dass es sozusagen ausgelöst durch diese Infektion, einfach so eine Autoimmunrispons ist, also dass der Körper einfach äh auf diese Infektion,
irgendwie reagiert und ähm ja.
Und das Immunsystem den eigenen Körper angreift, äh dann.
Genau, also das ist ja das, was Autoimmun eigentlich äh heißt, genauso kann man's sagen, ne. Es gibt auch noch,
Also Raum für andere Mechanismen, aber sagen wir mal, das ist so so ein bisschen so diese drei Hypothesen, die so ein bisschen im Raum stehen, soweit ich das verstanden habe
Und jetzt zeigt sich allerdings, dass wenn Leute geimpft werden, die diese Long-Cove haben, dass die zu einem bestimmten Teil.
Tatsächlich eine Verbesserung dieses Zustands äh erfahren können.
Also es äh macht den also das ist nicht bei allen so.
Aber wohl bei ausreichend vielen konnte man das schon beobachten, dass man davon ausgeht, dass es also hier durchaus ein eine positive Auswirkung gibt.
Ja und das sind doch irgendwie auch gute Nachrichten. Also es ist sozusagen so ein weiterer ähm.
Wo eine Impfung auch helfen kann, also dass sozusagen die dann in der Lage ist, das Immunsystem so hoch zu fahren, um dann halt einerseits entweder diese viralen Reservoire aufzulösen oder eben auch diese Fragmente dann äh komplett wegzufegen
oder eben dann auch diese Autoimmunsystem äh Reaktion zu bekämpfen selber.
Ich verlinke da auf einen entsprechenden Artikel, wo das beschrieben ist, da könnt ihr euch dann äh einen eigenen äh eigenes Bild äh von machen.
Und.
Related dazu auch noch ein zweiter Link. Ich quatsche da jetzt mal nicht so viel drüber, weil ich das nur interessant fand, aber äh ehrlich gesagt so im letzten Detail auch nicht durchgegangen bin, aber es gibt da eine schöne Grafik.
Sie verstanden.
Du hast es schon verstanden, das ist sehr schön.
Das ist äh im Economist erschienen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, wo das herkommt. Auf jeden Fall wurde hier untersucht, welche Folgen denn so Kowit neunzehn so
hat und zwar bei Leuten mit ähm
Also die sozusagen jetzt unterschiedlich betrachtet werden nach Männer und Frauen und äh Alter, aber eben auch Vorerkrankungen. Also welche Vorerkrankungen lösen jetzt eigentlich was aus.
Und da kann man sehr schön sehen, dass eben ja Tod nicht das einzige Problem ist.
Ne, also erstmal was auffällt ist, dass mit zunehmendem zunehmendem Alter.
Männer stärker von Tod betroffen sind als Frauen.
Kann vielleicht auch an einem allgemein schlechteren Gesundheitszustand von älteren Männern äh äh liegen, aber das läuft halt so. Ja, schon relativ schnell auseinander.
Und.
Dann äh kommen halt, also jetzt wenn man die Sterblichkeit betrachten jetzt erstmal die die Sterblichkeit ähm so. Ähm.
Und dann ähm ist es so, ja Diabetes äh ist halt so ein,
Faktor, der für ähm ja äh Cop D, also Lungen,
chronische wie das Ding auf Deutsch heißt, aber ja chronische Lungen, Lunge zu halt äh,
so, denn äh ja aber auch interessant äh Leute, die gerade äh chronische Nierenerkrankungen haben,
ist dann noch schlimmer, chronische Herzerkrankungen und aber am krassesten so das verdoppelt des Todesrisikofasen chronische Lebererkrankungen.
Das sind wir quasi jetzt bei dem, was äh sagen wir jetzt den Tod verursacht, aber dass der entscheidende Punkt, das hat eine Kurve, so die es eben altersabhängig und.
Prinzip bis zwanzig
ist diese Kurve total flach und steigt denn auch eigentlich bis ja so fünfzig, fünfundfünfzig eigentlich
kaum an. Also schon um den Faktor zehn also insofern nicht kaum, aber im Vergleich jetzt dann zu, ich sage mal, dann einem einem,
bis zu dreißig prozentigen Sterberisiko zum Beispiel, wenn du einen Mann mit einer chronischen Lebererkrankung bist und kriegst Kovit, dann sind so ja fünfunddreißig Prozent, also ein Drittel äh Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du stirbst, das ist halt so
die krasseste äh also die höchste Sterbewahrscheinlichkeit ähm aber wie gesagt ähm.
Der Unterschied ist halt unter sechzig hast du halt eher sowas wie ja äh null Komma zwei fünf Prozent dann sterbe,
Rate eigentlich, also äh und bei unter,
dreißig oder unter zwanzig sind's dann null Komma null zwei fünf so also überhaupt nicht mehr mehr sichtbar. So das heißt.
Tatsächlich junge Menschen sterben.
Fast gar nicht an dieser Krankheit so. Aber und das ist jetzt der entscheidende Punkt, weil es immer heißt, okay, junge Menschen sterben nicht.
Weil jetzt der Hospitalisierung äh sieht es aber anders aus.
Da haben wir halt äh auch bereits nach dieser Grafik
bei unter zwanzigjährigen hier einen Host beteiligten Risiko, was so zwischen ja fünf, fünf, sechs, sieben Prozent äh schon
liegt und dann bereits ganz schnell ansteigt so bei über zwanzigjährigen schon dann auf über zehn Prozent und,
bei,
Fünfunddreißigjährigen, ja bei vierzigjährigen erreicht's dann die zwanzig Prozent und so weiter, aber es geht halt maximal hoch dann unter den schlimmsten Bedingungen auf ungefähr ja.
Fünfundfünfzig, achtundfünfzig Prozent äh so, also.
Mit Vorerkrankungen, ne?
Mit Vorerkrankungen und und allem und über achtzig und so mit Vorerkrankungen ähm ist jeder zweite äh muss äh ins ins Krankenhaus,
Aber äh eben äh von den Jüngeren äh geht das Risiko nur u,
Faktor ja acht bis zehn ungefähr noch nicht mal ihr Faktor acht zurück. So, das heißt das.
Bleiben bleibt halt ein ein ja hundert Mal höheres Risiko für junge Leute hospitalisiert zu werden als zu sterben.
Heißt äh und das ist natürlich vor dem Hintergrund Belastung des Gesundheitssystems ist das natürlich ein Problem, weil.
Ja.
Ähm und ähm es ist eben auch so, ja, dass halt dann eben fünf bis zehn Prozent der Jüngeren, äh denen geht's dann schon so dreckig, dass sie halt ins Krankenhaus müssen.
Äh wobei mir tatsächlich ähm also das ist jetzt USA.
So ähm ich sollte eigentlich in der Lage sein, jetzt unabhängig von den ähm.
Von den Erkrankungen ähm.
Weil die Zahlen habe ich halt nicht, aber zumindest was so Geschlechter und Alter angeht,
sollte ich das zumindest teilweise in der Lage sein, das nachzuvollziehen oder auf deutsche Zahlen zu kommen? Und in Deutschland,
liegt die Hospitalisierungsrate im Schnitt.
Bei zehn Prozent. Also würde ich sagen, sind die Zahlen in Deutschland nicht ganz so krass wie.
Hier in den USA oder wie dieser Studie so, weil wie gesagt,
das scheint mir eher dann durchschnittlich auf einen Durchschnitt von EA zwanzig bis dreißig Prozent hinauszulaufen, wenn,
das so stimmt bei der, bei der entsprechenden Alterspyramide, aber nichtsdestotrotz, so was man mitnehmen kann, ist,
dass die Hospitalisierungs,
signifikant äh zumindest zu sein, scheint bei auch jungen Leuten und das ist ein Problem.
Weil das natürlich dann wieder in Verbindung mit Loncovit äh und so.
Ja das ist nicht harmlos für Jugendliche und Kinder. Auch wenn sie nicht sterben dran.
Genau, also man sollte ausreichend gewarnt sein, äh es ist nicht also es lässt sich einfach sehr gut messen, dass die Auswirkungen da sind und vor allem
Wenn man irgendeine,
spezielle Erkrankung hat und oft kennt man die ja vielleicht auch gar nicht, ja? Es ist sozusagen etwas, was was doch gar nicht sich so nach vorne geschoben hat. Ähm
Dann gehen diese Wahrscheinlichkeiten auch steil nach oben. Also das ist sozusagen das andere, was ich hier rauslese ist im Vergleich zu Kerngesund, was kaum einer ist,
machen diese ganzen Vorerkrankungen und in dem Fall ist es ja so eine Liste, also Herz äh Herzprobleme, Nierenversagen
lieber versagen oder was halt versagen, also Leberkrankheiten und Nierenkrankheiten, Diabetes, ja, das macht alles eine ganze Menge aus.
Na gut. Jetzt wollen wir euch nicht länger ähm ver,
schrecken mit all diesen ganzen medizinischen Kram. Vielleicht zum Schluss nochmal kurz äh die Sache mit den Schnelltests,
besprochen, ist ja quasi die die neue Sache,
Äh wie gesagt, wieder sehr schwierig von unserer Berliner Blase auf den Rest Deutschlands zu schließen, aber man kann hier zumindest beobachten, einerseits es gibt Tests zum kaufen in Supermärkten,
Tests zu kaufen auch online bei Versendern von Medikamenten und so weiter äh mit unterschiedlichen Lieferzeiten und ähm Verfügbarkeiten
Aber es gibt halt auch Schnelltests jetzt hier,
quasi wie Impfzentren gibt's jetzt auch Schnelltestzentren in größerer Zahl, wo man sich irgendwie Termine holen kann und aus manchen Bundesländern habe ich gehört, ja da bin ich hingegangen, dann wurde ich gleich getestet und fertig und in Berlin kriegt man einen Termin für nächste Woche.
Ja, was so ein bisschen, das das Thema schnell äh Test ad absurdum führt, aber gut.
Na ja, zumindest ist er ist er schnell ab dem Moment, wo man getestet wird, ne. Äh ich denke
das sind auch hier das Anlaufprobleme. Man muss ja nicht immer gleich drauf einhacken. Also ich
man immer so eben für achtzig Millionen Leute Schnelltest bereitzustellen und das zu organisieren, dass da nicht alles sofort läuft, das äh ist auch klar. Das will ich jetzt auch gar nicht weiter diskutieren, sondern ich wollte einfach nur mal so diskutieren, was denn jetzt eigentlich da ist
Und wenn man sich mal äh und das habe ich getan, bei so einem bei so einem Online-Dienst äh schaut, was was so was könnt ihr mir denn verkaufen? Dann ist man von einer.
Gibt es geradezu eine Flut von verschiedenen Schnelltests, die in Frage kommen.
Bisher gab's ja immer nur die, die äh so diesen Nasen äh Rückraum, der so ein bisschen eklig ist, ne? Weil man muss sich da hinten da so äh im Nasenrückraum machen. Das ist so ein bisschen sensitiv, da
kratzt man sich jetzt nicht den ganzen Tag und man muss da irgendwie niesen, manchen Leuten tut's auch weh ein bisschen, also gibt da, sagen wir mal, es ist jetzt nicht das Schönste, was man so machen kann
bringt einen auch nicht um und geht schon irgendwie, wenn man sich dran gewöhnt, aber geil ist es nicht und besonders uncool für Kinder und da man natürlich jetzt dieses Schnelltest auch vielleicht gerne haben möchte, um seine Kids zu checken. Na ja
gibt's dann halt auch noch andere Optionen. Was es also jetzt gibt, teilt sich aus meiner Perspektive im Wesentlichen den drei, wenn nicht sogar in vier verschiedene Kategorien ein. Einerseits welche
die eben für den Selbsttest auch gedacht sind, höhere ähm
Anwendbarkeit haben für einen normalen Nasenabstrich, also da reicht es dann sozusagen im Nasenraum, so ein bisschen so ein, ich sage mal so äh.
Tief popeln reicht. Man muss nicht bis ganz nach hinten äh durchstoßen.
Ins Gehirn.
Genau, nicht bis ins Gehirn so, das trifft's auch nicht, man man fuhrwerk da nicht im Gehirn rum. Es ist halt nur hinten und von daher ist es ein bisschen unangenehm. Ähm dann gibt's welche, die sagen, Rachenabstrich reicht,
Gibt auch welche, die sagen, entweder oder ist uns egal. Also es gibt da so alle Spielarten, jeder Test ist ein bisschen anders
Dann gibt's welche, die sagen Speichelprobereich.
Da bin ich noch ein bisschen skeptisch, ich habe mir trotzdem mal welche bestellt, sind aber leider noch nicht da. Das hat natürlich den riesen Vorteil, dass wenn man da äh Ergebnisse erzielen kann, die zuverlässig sind und die Dinger sind ja alle getestet, also,
Davon gehe ich jetzt mal aus, ne? Das das sie schon mal auch irgendwie äh ihre ihre Wirkung haben in irgendeiner Form nachweisen müssen. Das heißt, da reicht dann irgendwie äh reinspucken
Ja und äh dann gibt's auch noch diese Gurgel-Tests, da habe ich noch nicht so hundertprozentig verstanden, wie die eigentlich funktionieren und wie die vor allem im Vergleich
sind auf jeden Fall, dass es so ein bisschen zu diese Bandbreite. Wenn man diese online kauft, kosten die ungefähr sowas in der Größenordnung von vier, fünf Euro pro Test
und werden in unterschiedlichen Packungsgrößen abgegeben von irgendwie fünf pro Packung bis irgendwie fünfundzwanzig und noch größere Mengen.
Ja und das kommt jetzt sozusagen mit äh in den Mix und es wird spannend sein
abzuwarten, was das sozusagen auslösen kann. Abgesehen jetzt von dieser
immer wiederkehrenden Diskussionen, ob denn das jetzt hier unsere Testzahlen beeinflussen, ob wir dann auf einmal mehr Fälle sehen und so weiter. Ich glaube, die Diskussion kann man auch mal ein bisschen beiseite legen, weil,
Ja, vielleicht sehen wir dann mehr Fälle, aber die gibt's ja dann auch. Also ich meine, die Leute werden ja dann auch getestet und sind positiv und ist immer besser, das zu finden, als nicht zu finden. Von daher denke ich mal, wird das schon eine positive Wirkung haben. Ähm.
Also es wäre blöd, wenn wir nicht mehr Fälle finden äh äh würden damit,
Äh so ähm ja.
Ja, muss man, muss man einfach sehen. Also das ist einfach glaube ich zu früh, das machen wir jetzt auch noch ein bisschen unklar, wie das so im Testregime ist, also wenn jetzt wenn ich hier in so ein Schnelltestzentrum gehe und da positiv getestet werde.
Passiert, dann wird das dann schon gemeldet irgendwie oder muss muss man dann automatisch einen BCR-Test machen oder wie? Das das weiß ich alles noch nicht, das werden wir dann sehen.
Aber was das natürlich jetzt auch äh perspektivisch natürlich eröffnet ist quasi eine Perspektive zum Eröffnen,
Das hatten wir hier glaube ich auch vor einem halben Jahr schon mal diskutiert. Da kamen ja diese Vorschläge aus dem Fußballbereich
Damals wurden dann die Leute, die diese Ideen hatten, auch noch gleich mit Scheiße beworfen, weil wie man denn nur könnte, über sowas zu diskutieren. Die Zeiten haben sich mittlerweile, glaube ich, auch geändert und es wird jetzt in Berlin einen.
Ja ein Testlauf geben, so ein Pilotprojekt, das beginnt nächste Woche
am neunzehnten März und läuft bis zum vierten April. Und was da gemacht wird ist, dass es eben ausgewählte Veranstaltungen gibt und zwar aus einem sehr breiten, kulturellen Umfeld
Äh Opa, Konzerte, Clubs
Alles Mögliche und auch nicht nur so die Hochkultur, sondern auch die Subkultur
alle können sich daran beteiligen, also ich bin mir jetzt hier gar nicht so sicher, wie viele es sind, aber es ist sagen wir mal ein relativ
großer Teil, wo es dann eben so laufen wird, dass Veranstaltungen stattfinden und wer da hinkommen woll, der macht halt vorher so einen Schnelltest.
Das ist also dann in irgendeiner Form arrangiert, dass man eben in der Nähe des Venus so einen Schnelltest machen kann, nach fünfzehn Minuten das Ergebnis bekommt und wenn's halt nicht positiv ist, der Test, dann darf man halt rein,
Und dann wahrscheinlich immer noch mit Masten und so weiter, aber.
Ne? Das wird man dann sehen. Einerseits, ob's was bringt, andererseits, wie das so vom Handling ist, wie das vom Aufwand her ist, ob das angemessen ist, ob man daran noch was ändern muss und nicht könnte mir durchaus vorstellen
dass wenn das positiv läuft, dass wir dann sozusagen ein ähm ja Ablauf ähm
Vorgaben bekommen werden, wie denn künftig
Veranstaltungen aller Art stattfinden können unter Einbeziehung von solchen Schnelltests. Für Veranstaltung unterschiedliche Größe.
In Abhängigkeit des weiteren Verlaufs der Pandemie.
Ja
Mein äh mein Verein hier Union Berlin macht da auch mit, allerdings nicht mit öffentlichen Teilnehmern, sondern im Fußball ist es ja so, dass der die Bundesliga hat ja,
Profifußball hat ja eh schon die ganze Zeit so eine Ausnahmegenehmigung gehabt mit dem entsprechenden Aufwand, der da getrieben werden muss, dass ja alle.
Die,
zum engen Betrieb gehören, also die Spielertrainer, Betreuer und so weiter, die müssen ja sowieso regelmäßig PCR-Tests machen, also die machen irgendwie zwei PCR-Test pro Woche.
Und am Spieltag
gibt's dann eben nochmal so diese ganze also dann gibt's ja so eine Zonenaufteilung, das heißt es gibt so Zone A, da müssen alle PCR getestet sein und dann gibt's irgendwie Zone, BCD, weiß ich nicht ganz genau, je nachdem wie nah man da am Geschehen ist
sagen wir mal so zum Beispiel Journalisten,
meines Wissens äh reicht es dann auch da mit irgendwie Fiebertest und anderen äh Sachen durchzukommen. Die müssen jetzt nicht unbedingt immer mit einem PCR-Test kommen. Kann durchaus sein, dass sich das alles auf Schnelltest ändert, aber dann eben auch die
Teilnehmerzahl vergrößern kann. Union testet das jetzt mal.
Unter dem Aspekt, äh was sind das überhaupt für ein logistischer Aufwand ist? Also die erhöhen jetzt nicht die Anzahl der Leute, die da ohnehin wäre, sondern.
Nehmen einfach die, die sowieso kommen und zugelassen sind und fügen quasi das Schnelltesten hinzu, um zu schauen, was da so passiert.
Ja, also ich meine gut,
wenn sie's tatsächlich hinkriegen, dass es dazu keinerlei Übertragung oder Infektion kommt. Ich meine, ich fände es immer noch besser, wenn wir einfach jetzt mal die Zahlen äh wirklich runtergebracht hätten.
Aber äh und und dann in Ruhe.
Mit äh Testen und äh äh Masken ähm für Sicherheit sorgen können oder den dann,
ganz nach unten arbeiten, na schauen wir mal. Also hm.
Sagt in Berlin fallen ja die Zahlen gerade, aber im Bund steigen sie.
Wird, wird spannend. Also eigentlich müssten sie denn in Berlin demnächst aber auch wieder anziehen nach aller Logik. Ähm.
Es sei denn, es geschieht ein Wunder. Das könnte auch sein.
Genau. Genau, also.
Trump hat eigentlich genau vor einem Jahr ein Wunder auch vorhergesagt. It will magic lee disipier, vielleicht passiert das ja jetzt.
Erhöht sich nur im Jahr vertan.
Ja, kann schon sein. Der hat sich ja ziemlich oft.
Also ich ich find's ja super, äh wenn das einfach verschwinden würde. Ich würde mich total freuen und äh ja wird irgendwie ja.
Ich war begeistert. Aber ähm ja leider.
Erwarten oder drauf verlassen äh äh können wir uns nicht, das wäre glaube ich äh ziemlich irre, weil wir halt,
sehen, wozu das führt, wenn man das macht, so wie, was weiß ich, Leute in Tschechien oder in Estland oder also,
es gibt noch ganz ganz viele potenzielle Überraschungen die auf uns zukommen können bis hin zu
es könnte auch sein, dass die Zahlen im Moment deshalb runtergehen, weil die Viren gelernt haben
den Tests auszuweichen, weil es halt vielleicht Stämme gibt, die wir noch gar nicht erkannt haben. Ähm.
So gut es.
Uns dem Ende der Sendung, Pavel, du weißt, dass wir jetzt langsam.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Positiven Ausblick kommen müssen.
Was der positive Ausblick ist der, dass offenbar jetzt das Sequenzieren in großen Maßstab wohl tatsächlich auch.
Anläuft, das heißt das wir hoffentlich dann demnächst wenigstens an der Mutationsfront ähm,
auch ja zu anderen Ländern halt aufschließen, äh was so,
Überwachen von Mutanten äh angeht, was dringend geboten ist, weil das ist
sagen fast auch noch die größte unbekannte, die da auf uns zukommen kann, die uns halt überraschen kann und unsere bisherigen Strategien komplett übern Haufen äh werfen,
kann. Ja, insofern ähm.
Zurückhaltung, aber ich bin trotzdem relativ verhalten, optimistisch, was dieses Schnelltestregime betrifft. Also das zumindest bestimmte Formen von Veranstaltungen
dadurch vielleicht stattfinden können, weil sie einfach so ein kontrolliertes Entwarnen macht. Ich meine Veranstaltungen haben jetzt viel gelitten und haben viele, viele Nachteile. Aber sie haben auch einen Vorteil,
Sie haben in der Regel ähm so einen definierten Endrepoint,
Also sozusagen dieses kontrollische Regime, wer darf hier rein, das ist ohnehin Bestandteil des Ganzen. Und wenn man das Kontrollregime eben richtig organisiert bekommt und sagt, okay, wir reduzieren jetzt hier mal die Wahrscheinlichkeit und
Am Ende kann es nie etwas anderes sein, ne? Weil.
Selbst wenn wir Institzen von drei haben, ist halt irgendjemand noch infiziert, so, ne?
Und dann kann man eben durch so ein schnelltes Regime diese Wahrscheinlichkeiten senken. Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite, wenn ihr jetzt mal, wenn man das jetzt mal hochskalieren auf so ein Fußballstadion, jetzt sagen wir mal zweiundzwanzigtausend Teilnehmern.
Und du testest alle durch. Vor so einer Veranstaltung.
Je nachdem wie sehr gerade das Virus da draußen so läuft, wirst du halt auch einfach welche finden. Welche, die es nicht wussten.
Oder die es vielleicht wussten und nicht wahrhaben wollten oder,
sich nicht getraut haben, zu testen oder keine Ahnung, was sie so gedacht haben in dem Moment, aber die dann eben,
rausfallen. Es wird ein paar geben, die werden dann einen Fehlalarm sein. Denen wird gesagt, du bist ja positiv. Ich sehe hier einen Strich.
Die ist aber gar nicht warm, ja? Und es wird welche geben, die vielleicht.
Gerade so kurz davor sind äh richtig infektiös zu werden, aber wo dieser Test aus irgendwelchen Gründen
nicht die richtige Probe entnommen hat. Klar, die wird's geben, aber dann werden jetzt auch nicht gleich zweiundzwanzigtausend Leute infiziert nach Hause gehen, weil du halt immer noch ein Stadion hast, wo vielleicht Masten getragen werden.
Also ähm.
Ich würde das so überschlagen bei zwanzigtausend Leuten, wenn du zwanzigtausend Leute ins Stadion lässt. Im Moment.
Sagt meine Risikotabelle ist so jeder fünfhundertneunzigste davon ungefähr äh infiziert.
Und,
Jetzt ist die Frage, wie viel Prozent von den Infizierten äh äh laufen äh draußen rum, weil ähm ja, von denen äh egal. Also,
Auf jeden Fall ist es größtenordnungsmäßig, sind es jetzt dreißig Leute.
So äh von den zwanzigtausend, die du erwarten kannst, die irgendwie ähm,
infiziert sind. So, davon testen dann jetzt, da kommt's jetzt drauf an, wie gut der Test ist. Wie ist dort die Volksengativ.
Rate. Ähm,
so äh aber es kann durchaus sein, dass so also die ist halt nicht bei hundert Prozent. So.
Bei denen gerade bei den Schnelltests, also wenn du jetzt zwanzigtausend Leute kennt ja aber größenordnungsmäßig sag mal eine Hand voll ein bis drei Leute ungefähr äh rutschen durch.
Wahrscheinlich sind es auch Leute, die dann nicht so die allerhöchste Viruslast äh haben und da wir halt wissen, dass
sagen ja zehn Prozent der Leute für achtzig Prozent der Infektionen of.
Verantwortlich sind.
Ich würde sagen, es ist ungefähr mit Testeinsatz ist es fifty fifty, dass es zu Übertragungen kommt äh bei einem Fußballspiel, was von zwanzigtausend Leuten besucht wird und durch Schnelltests abgesichert ist.
Zu irgendeiner Übertragung kommt.
Zu irgendeiner Übertragung kommt. Ja.
Vorausgesetzt, es werden keine Masken zu tragen.
Ja, Masten helfen natürlich dann auch nochmal äh äh so, hm.
Es ist draußen.
Ja, ja ich sage mal wahrscheinlich äh infizieren sich auf dem Weg dahin oder so äh ja deutlich deutlich mehr Leute als dann im Stadion. Äh.
Okay. Das andere Problem. Ja, na gut, wie man's macht, äh ja, wir müssen erstmal zum Ende kommen. Pavel, haben wir noch einen Abschluss, Sermon.
Nee, ich bin tatsächlich auch äh schon jetzt ganz gut durch. Wir haben jetzt auch schon wieder Mitternach.
Drei Stunden, ja.
Die drei Stunden ja.
Glaub so viel Interessantes zu erzählen. Na gut, dann machen wir es doch einfach kurz. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, wenn ihr es bis hierhin äh geschafft habt. Ich hoffe, es war wieder was für euch dabei,
Wir äh freuen uns über euer Feedback in den Kommentaren. Wir freuen uns auch, wenn ihr unserer wöchentlichen Dienstags, einundzwanzig Uhr Clubhausrunde beiwohnt mit interessanten,
Rückmeldung oder Fragen und wenn ihr dann nicht dabei sein könnt oder wollt, dann.
Nächste Woche wieder von uns von UKW, Korona Wickly. Jetzt machen wir mal äh zu den Laden und wir schauen mal,
Was wir noch aus Pavels toller Tabelle äh in den nächsten sieben Tagen alles für interessante Informationen rausgeschält bekommen. Bleibt auf jeden Fall spannend. Ähm.
Wir wünschen euch noch viel Spaß mit der dritten Welle und bleibt tapfer und bleibt gesund und.